Usually I have it,
but it goes away after a month or so.
I've had it for like four months.
Pretty solid.
Ooh.
And we live Cam Haynes.
Hey Dude,
buddy.
I'm good.
How are you?
Welcome to California.
I know.
And that this place is amazing.
It's pretty bad ass,
right?
Yeah,
we did the,
we did the grand tour and I'm ready to
lift.
Yeah,
we're gonna.
We're going to shoot first and I don't
want you,
you want to have poor accuracy.
No,
you're,
you're whole motto of run,
lift.
Shoot.
Shouldn't be chute lift,
run or shoot,
run,
lift.
I Dunno.
Do you,
do you,
you've run in the mornings and then you
run at night too,
right?
Yeah.
You have a problem.
That's a problem.
Yeah.
That's too much.
Well,
I just fell back on that.
Moderation is for cowards.
So that like pretty much covers any
psycho over doing in excess.
I'm like just,
he can be like,
no,
I'm just not a coward.
And what about overtraining?
Is that bullshit?
Yeah.
It's totally bullshit.
But you were saying before,
that's when you were 20.
You're 50 now,
but when you were 20,
you could never do what you can do now
when you're 50 now.
So if you tried to do what you do now at
50 when you were 20,
wouldn't it be overtraining?
I'm confused.
Well,
I mean,
if you weren't in shape enough,
obviously you're in great shape.
Could you do this all the time?
But if you weren't sure
and you tried to keep this up like what
you're doing right now?
Yeah,
no,
I,
I feel,
I dunno.
I feel good.
Who was here?
Jamie?
Somebody just walked in delivery.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
so when you were 20,
did you do anything?
Um,
I mean,
I've always been active.
Right.
You know,
I always played sports and ran at 10 k
in the summers and things like that.
So just worked out a little or
something.
Yeah.
I just wanted to lift a little bit,
but not to the level I'm at now.
Yeah.
Well,
when I look at your instagram,
I get tired.
Yeah,
I do.
Because you're doing all that shit,
especially that shit.
You're dealing with a outlaw strength.
Yeah.
Eric.
Eric,
yeah.
Yeah.
I lost trength on instagram.
You guys are doing ridiculous amounts of
reps.
Yeah,
we do.
It's,
it's all about the reps and it's like,
uh,
I dunno.
And like I say,
your body gets used to what you ask of
it.
You know?
If I would have tried to do that exact
same thing when I was young,
no way.
I mean,
it'd be probably be so sore.
I couldn't do anything for a week.
Yeah,
that's what I was thinking.
Also when I was looking at,
I was like,
if you stopped doing this,
how long will it take before it slides
off a one day?
Because when I don't work out for one
day,
I'm skinny,
fat and weak.
How might no for real?
Like how many days,
what's the longest you've ever taken
off?
Oh,
probably hunting.
okay.
If I'm at home,
I don't,
I would never take any time off.
But when I'm hunting,
because that's what I'm,
you know,
therefore.
Right.
But when you're hunting,
at least you're hiking a lot of physical
activity and there's a lot going on
there.
But I want to watch your videos,
those instagram videos of you guys.
Okay.
We're going to do a hundred reps of dog
to do a hundred reps
of that.
Yeah.
Cause right now I told you I'm suffering
through this little tendinitis things
I've been trying to fight off.
I saw,
I see all those reps and my elbow starts
hurting when I'm looking at the screen.
Yeah.
You know,
people ask me about,
my joints are about,
you know,
cause they're battling different things
like that.
And I have no idea.
I mean I just,
I don't have,
I've been lucky where I don't have
injuries.
You know?
I mean that's very disappointing.
Yeah.
I mean I,
you know,
my banged up a little bit,
but um,
you know,
I've talked to you before where I've had
to take an advil every day and I'm not
anymore.
Well w tell that story because that's a
crazy story and I've talked about it on
the podcast without you being here,
but I called you after Rhonda.
Patrick did a podcast with me and she
was telling me about the dangers of what
they call nonsteroidal
antiinflammatories.
That's what I can profane is right.
And she was saying it,
it ruins your gut biome and then it
actually causes inflammation.
And so that people that are taking advil
every day for inflammation don't even
realize that taking all that advil
actually is causing inflammation.
Right?
Yeah.
So you quit.
I quit.
And uh,
then I wasn't,
and I almost think it was maybe placebo
a little bit because it's like not only
did it not help after a while,
but it made it worse,
essentially the inflammation.
So after hearing that,
and you know,
who's ever going to question Rhonda
Patrick,
and I would never,
so I'm like,
well,
I'd better stop that.
So,
um,
since then I haven't been taking
anything.
And then I have taken,
there's this,
you can get at the health food store.
It's called Kratom.
Oh yeah.
You ever heard of that?
Yeah.
That,
that seems to help.
You know,
they're trying to outlaw that stuff.
Yeah.
Apparently that's that Kratom stuff.
I had Chris Bell on the podcast,
he's doing a documentary about Kratom
and he did that documentary bigger,
stronger,
faster.
And yeah,
I know who he is.
He brought in some guys that sell Kratom
and they were explaining what it does.
And I tried it and when I tried it,
apparently if you take it in low doses,
it's like almost a mild stimulant,
which is what it felt like to me.
But if you take it in higher doses,
it relaxes you and it's really good for
pain.
And Chris has had a hip replacements.
What'd he say about it?
Was a positive or not positive?
There's no negative.
There's no downsides to it.
It's not addictive.
It's not bad for you.
It's a,
it's an herb.
It's not toxic at all.
Right.
So that's,
I mean if it,
so of course the government's trying to
make it illegal.
Oh,
I,
you can't have stuff out there that
actually helps.
Yeah.
They're trying to label it with fucking
heroin and shit and it's just,
they're so crazy.
Yeah.
No,
it's a,
but I think that's helped.
But other than that,
I don't take any,
I mean nothing and I feel great.
That's crazy.
That's amazing.
So when you're doing all these reps,
like,
so you do and you,
you do these crazy things on like the
lat pull down machine where you,
you do the whole stack,
right?
The goal
is 20 of the stack of everything.
That's fucking ridiculous.
So how do you not get like joint pain
that doesn't have anything?
No.
So just because you do it all the time,
I'm not sure.
Addition to it.
I can't make me want to do it.
I know it's,
but I don't want people to,
uh,
I mean it's taken a while to work up
there.
Right.
So,
I mean,
I,
I don't want people to go and try to do
that right out of the gate and then get
hurt because that's what I think that's
what frustrates people more than
anything is when they're excited to make
a change of lifestyle change and then
they,
something happens and then,
you know,
they get hurt.
Yeah.
I was doing chin ups,
um,
three or four times a week I decided I
was going to do 50 chin ups,
uh,
at least three or four times a week.
Just,
just make sure I did them all the time.
And then on top of that I was doing
heavy cleans,
90 pound cleans with kettlebells,
cleans and presses.
I started getting this whole nagging
elbow pain.
Yeah.
And I didn't want to be a pussy,
so I kept working out through it.
Yeah.
It would be fine.
Like,
um,
during the workout it'd be fine.
Like it would start to hurt at the
beginning of the workout,
but then once the blood would get flown,
then it would be fine.
And then after a couple of weeks of
that,
it my,
my arms like,
Hey,
fuck head.
Yeah,
this is enough of this.
Yeah.
Cleans their tough though,
you know,
things are hard.
I mean,
I,
I know,
I know what I can get away with.
Um,
I don't do dead lifts,
you know,
I used to do dead lifts.
I used to do all this stuff.
Now I'm like,
you know,
even though I want to do,
I want to maybe every once in a while
tried dead lift and cause I know it
feels good.
I mean my hamstrings feel good,
my back feels strong when you're all,
everything works right.
But I just know that it's just,
it's just not smart because there's a
high possibility that the chick,
you go sell something,
something gets tweaked in the bottom and
then you know,
it's one side and then it's,
you know,
I feel it down my leg and I'm like not,
I don't want to be that.
You're taking that hundred 30 pound rock
and throw it in a backpack.
Going up mountains with that.
You still doing that?
No,
it's gone.
My rocks gone.
What happened?
The Rock,
I don't know.
Somebody stole it I guess so you will
even in the same spot,
roller it off the side of the mountain.
There's some due to probably jerks off
on that rock and away.
This is Kim Haines.
Rough sounds fun.
I wouldn't be surprised.
I've seen a lot of things online.
Oh yeah.
There's some,
there's some great people and there's
some crazy people.
Oh this is mostly great people.
Yeah,
for sure.
I find that my interactions online or
almost mostly positive,
the fuck.
Like by far the problem is that's like
having mostly non poisonous food.
Yeah.
A little bit of poison enough.
Oh,
you'd have to do is go to this
restaurant one out of 10 times they
fucking poison.
You'd never go back to that restaurant
and yeah,
I don't even think it's one out of 10 I
think that the interactions that I have
online that are negative,
it's not even one out of 100 now.
I don't think so.
Those,
for me,
those are the ones that I am drawn to
and I find myself,
I see the negative,
I go pass all these positive
and then I'll say something because I
just,
if I'm in a bad mood after a whole day
of getting beat down by stupid comments
and I'll have to do something and then
I'll be like,
why did I,
so then I go back and like try to
acknowledge some positive ones because I
feel guilty.
Well,
I saw you post a picture of a bear that
you shot the other day.
It was a video of a berry shot.
And I said,
Ooh,
I looked at those comments.
I'm like,
here we go.
Which one was,
it was a you,
you,
you shot a bear and you were opening its
mouth.
The children's teeth.
Oh,
ah,
yeah,
for sure.
And I saw that video and I was like,
Whoa,
that's a landmine right there.
I know bear,
you know,
bears crazy.
It is.
That is the,
the one animal that I think people have
the most distorted perceptions up cause
it teddy bears.
Because Yogi and because I really want
to take anybody who has these weird
thoughts about bears,
I just really want to bring them to John
and John's place in Alberta.
And I want to say,
why don't you are going to come hang
around and if we're lucky we're going to
see a bear tear apart a baby bear.
Because they do that every day.
All the time.
They get up out of their dens and they
go looking for baby bears.
Yeah.
And then maybe if we're lucky,
we'll see a bear get ahold of a fawn and
it'll be crying and it'll eat,
eat,
eat that thing alive.
They'll have a different,
they'll have a different take on it.
They'll be like,
kill that.
Yeah.
Or just people are nuts.
They're trying to bring wolves into
California or Colorado Rather.
We're talking about bringing wolves into
Colorado.
Like,
okay,
listen folks,
you don't have to do that.
You don't,
you already have bears.
You know,
I saw this the other day.
I think I've put up,
I think it was what inspired me to put
up there was a wolf video I posted.
There's some great wildlife videos out
there.
Oh,
it's crazy now.
Right?
Um,
great.
Not,
not,
they can be emotional.
Like with that bear kill on the,
the delcath was crying.
That was really,
I don't even like to see that.
I mean I'm a hunter,
but,
uh,
there's one or these wolves were chasing
down this calwell elk.
And you know,
that's not a quick process.
And I put that up because I had seen a
couple of celebrities and I don't even
know who the hell they are.
Movie Stars I think or something.
But they're saved the wolf fond or some
wolf bullshit and they're like Halloween
there to humans and they were howling
like they were wolves.
Woof.
And it's like,
I dunno,
I mean wolves are great wills or I had
wolves or one of my favorite animals,
you know,
called the Wild White Fang.
Those books.
I love those Jack London books when I
was young.
So wolves have always held a special
place in my heart,
but if they're straight killers.
Yeah.
So I mean I'm not hating on him for
doing that,
but you just can't have wolves running
around everywhere.
We can't,
you can understand right.
In my neighborhood,
yeah.
I was uh,
at home the other,
I made a recording of this cause I was
at home.
My dogs are barking like crazy.
It's like nine o'clock at night just
wow.
It's like what the fuck is going on?
And I step outside and these coyotes are
like a half a block away from my house.
Just scream,
man.
Those are wolves.
Those are little wools.
Yeah.
And they got ahold of something and then
celebrating some dude sent me a video
that's on his page of a,
it's a compilation of all these videos
from security cameras of coyotes killing
cats and dogs.
Yeah,
yeah.
Those are wolves.
That's what they do.
Those are the little bulbs.
That's all they are.
They can breed with wolves.
I mean,
they literally are wolves.
It's a it,
it's a fascinating thing that the
disconnect that people have with
predators,
you know,
and I look,
if I was in Idaho or Montana and I saw
wolves,
I'd be pumped.
I think.
I would think it would be awesome.
But he got to keep an eye on those
things,
folks.
Yeah.
You know,
there's a reason why they killed him off
150 years ago and it wasn't because
they're awesome.
It's because they will kill people.
They will kill your kids.
They will kill your dog.
They will.
They,
they.
I've seen wolves in the wild.
I saw a pack on Prince of Wales Island
one time.
They came down to the,
to the water once.
And I've seen him,
I had a wolf tag actually when I was in
British Columbia hunting buffalo and I
thought it was going to get a,
a shot at a wolf,
um,
up there.
But I never have,
but they give tags up there because
they're trying to diminish the
population.
Yeah.
I mean they have too many.
It's 50 bucks.
It's the same as in Alberta.
I mean,
you,
you would get our bear tags to go when
we go up there to John and gins and you
know,
$50 for a wolf tag also.
So it's not like there's a low number of
wolves,
you know,
but every time I've seen him,
I have been in a certain amount of awe
just because had been like this,
this amazing animal for my entire life.
And I've just,
it's hard not to look at a wolf and not
think regal and wild and,
and you know,
there's that saying that,
um,
you know,
you'll see bears and lions in the
circus,
but you'll never see a wolf.
You know,
they're just,
and I did the commercial with the wolf
to was amazing,
but uh,
well then under armor commercial you
told him it was pretty crazy because
they had this scene where the wolf
snarls and they had a save that scene
for the very end.
Yeah.
Because it was,
they said it was supposed to be me
against a wolf going after this hill.
And then I ended up winning that little,
the story as it was told and um,
they needed to get to wolf snarling.
And so they brought some meat out,
gave it some meat,
but they said,
well,
actually gave it then took it away.
And obviously that's going to make any
animal upset,
especially a wolf.
But they said,
once we do that,
we're done with the wolf because it's,
it's not going to just snap out of it
and it's just going to,
that's going to be it's mindset for a
while about it's not going to be happy.
Yeah,
there it is.
Yeah.
Go back to that.
I think it shows that end.
It should.
Yeah.
And that was actually,
I mean people thought that that was
edited and,
and it wasn't,
you know,
right there with me knowledge right
there with me.
Um,
you know,
they did a great job of putting that
commercial together.
Uh,
it wasn't necessarily snarling up me or
growling at me,
but it was there.
It was,
it was fun.
That was a big was at wolf.
I think it was about 130 pounds.
I mean he's tall that,
that's a big,
that's what surprised me is how tall
they are.
Long legs.
Right.
Yeah.
And I think,
you know,
we were talking about earlier,
as far as endurance goes,
wolves I believe are the number one
animal out there as far as they can run
miles and miles and miles and they're
tall and they can just,
you know,
their gate is uh,
whatever it allows them to go for hours
and miles.
Yeah.
I was talking about running with my dog,
you know,
and he's only a year old and he's in
such good shape now cause he runs with
me all the time.
Yeah.
See if we run two miles,
I run two miles,
he runs seven or eight.
Right.
Cause he's running over and back and up
and back and up and back and yeah,
but it's amazing.
Like what,
how good a shape they're in right out of
the box.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's a fucking puppy and he just books
it up that hill.
Just,
yeah.
He turns around and looks at me like,
come on bitch.
I know.
And he comes running back to me.
Yeah.
Animals,
you know,
uh,
animals pretty much have the advantage
over us on everything other than,
you know,
the,
I mean,
they're stronger,
stronger jaws.
Uh,
you know,
the Ma,
you're their muscles stronger for what
they have.
Um,
we have an endurance as a advantage over
most animals,
like elk.
But,
uh,
luckily we have,
you know,
we can use our minds.
Well,
that is the reason why we're so weak.
You know,
it's so fascinating how things balance
out.
It's like the US using our mind,
creating houses and cities and cars and
just sitting in a chair all day.
It makes you soft,
but then you figured out how to make a
gun.
Yeah.
And that balances everything out.
Unless the gun jams and then nature
comes back into play.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
All these people that are,
you know,
into the wolf,
save the wolf,
the wolves.
Okay.
Like you guys go to Idaho,
like people are freaking out up there
like the wolves are okay.
Oh,
like they,
they're,
they're starting to,
you know,
you go to,
um,
Alaska.
I was in a park city recently in Utah
and uh,
when I was there,
they,
uh,
we went to a store that had a wolf rug
and I was like,
Jesus,
I'm like yourself selling a wolf rug.
And the guy explained to me,
he said,
well,
these wolves are all shot by the
government in Alaska because they're
overpopulated.
So they're in these areas where they're
trying to protect the Moose population
for these,
uh,
the indigenous people that are so
subsistence hunters and live up there
and they have like a certain quota.
And he's like,
so it's actually
like,
it's a good thing to sell these rugs
because they're going to shoot these
wolves no matter what.
They're trying to keep the populations
in check.
And I think that's,
that's something that these people that
have the pictures see that problem of
like celebrities,
missoula.
They probably didn't think that shit
through it all.
They just think this is a cool thing to
be a part.
Of course everybody wants wolves to
live.
I'll just go and say we've got to
support the wolf,
we've got to save the wolf.
And so it's like,
it looks like a cool thing for you to be
a part of.
I think one of them was,
would have been Lisa Bonet Aa isn't,
she's like kind of a hippie.
Right?
She's a super hippie.
Yeah.
She's got a nose ring.
Everything.
She's always,
she's pretty,
I remember that.
But yeah,
remember it's in a find that bill cosby
was mad at her cause she was naked in a
movie.
Remember she was naked and Angel Heart
had mickey work and he was mad at that.
Huh?
Who's mad at that net?
Funny.
Yeah.
Funny how things work out.
It's ironical.
Yeah.
It is ironical.
I mean,
I look,
I dunno,
I think wolves are awesome.
Don't get me wrong folks.
Just,
I just don't think,
and this is,
this was me too,
before I started hunting for,
I started taking regular trips into the
woods.
You know,
you don't get it.
You just don't get it.
You got to go there.
You do.
If you don't go there,
you don't get it.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
uh,
we try to tell the story,
we're telling the story and it's getting
through to some people.
I mean,
I can see it,
I can see the,
there's education there.
I mean,
and I'm sure you get messages every day
from people who have never hunted,
who are interested in it,
who just want to know what the lifestyle
is.
Because we,
we've sort of romanticize the lifestyle
and,
and it's,
and it's easy to do because it's the
mountains and the mountains are,
you know,
you get that connection and you get that
empowerment.
Um,
so I,
I think we are kind of turning the tide
a little bit.
I got a message from a guy a while back
maybe four or five months ago,
who was a Vegan for a long time,
started listening to the podcast at
first,
was upset about the talk about hunting,
ran into some health issues.
His doctor recommended.
He started eating animal products again,
started with eggs,
worked his way back up to meet eight
meet again.
It was getting,
you know,
healthy grass fed,
uh,
you know,
ethically sustained animals,
ethically raised animals,
decided to go hunting,
became a hunter,
shot his first deer,
ate as far as deer and now he's going to
be a hunter.
Yeah.
I mean this guy went full circle,
right.
And part of the journey of him going for
full circle was listening to people talk
about it on the podcast and realizing
this idea that he had in his head that
these people that are out there hunting
are all people that hate animals and
they're cruel and they're just rednecks
that are going out there drinking beer
and shooting these animals and laughing
and hooting and hollering about it.
Yeah.
You know,
well there's a couple of points I want
to make there.
One of them is your podcast has been
amazing for the education part.
And I
mentioned this,
uh,
Adam and I did a podcast at the gritty
bowman and,
um,
I said,
you know,
Joe's podcast,
just because the,
the type of person Joe is,
is as far as being open minded,
um,
and giving everything a chance,
not,
not coming in with biases or the same
type of listeners you have,
you've kind of cultivated or,
or you know,
they,
they like you because I don't know,
they see themselves in you may be,
but anyway,
so those people have come in and listen
to these podcasts like this without that
bias.
And when you listen to it and listened
to us talk about it,
it's not the Redneck,
you know,
laughing cause they're killing things
person.
They may have thought it's,
you know,
this whole thing,
this whole thing we talk about.
And so this podcast in particular is I
think been a huge tool as far as
promoting hunting and ethical hunting
and um,
just the empowerment of being a hunter.
And so that,
I don't know,
just,
just this venue.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if we could ever done that
without,
you know,
the Joe Rogan podcast.
It's been amazing.
Um,
I dunno,
have you noticed that?
I mean with,
with other things besides hunting?
Um,
I think floating,
uh,
that's a big thing.
Yeah.
Sensory deprivation tanks that that
business was going under.
There was virtually no tank centers in
the world.
There was a,
like one of them in Burbank and I had
heard one of them was in San Francisco.
They're just,
they were hard to find.
There was none in New York.
Like one guy had one in an apartment in
New York that you could rent out.
A guy had one like that in his house in
Vegas that you could rent out.
There was none.
And now there's hundreds of data centers
all over the world and we've been using
the form.
Dude,
I got one in 2002.
I bought a house,
the house had a basement and I bought
the house with the basement just being
for two reasons.
One.
Um,
because,
uh,
I wanted to put a tank in there and two,
because the yard was big so I could have
my dogs running around the yard.
Yeah.
Just wanted to have a yard with the
dogs,
could run around.
Those are my two requirements for house.
Everything else was like,
I really don't give a shit about it.
And as long as there's the TV sits there
and okay,
here's where the bed goes.
I'm a man,
you know,
I don't know.
It's things that are living in deal
sweat when it comes to houses.
That dude's just don't sweat.
But for me,
a big one was,
I tried to tank a couple of times at
this place called soothing solutions in
Burbank.
I don't even know if it's around
anymore,
but um,
and then,
uh,
I put a tank in my basement and then I
started ranting and raving about it and
doing these youtube videos about it.
And then I got a new tank from the float
lab,
so I gave my old tank away online.
It had like a raffle,
not raffle,
but like a random draw.
I said,
just send me an email.
I gave an email address out and I'll
just pick a random person.
So I literally just scroll through my
email.
I'm like bank right there and pick this
guy out and set my tank to him and had
it set up and sent the salt down to
them,
the little deal.
And then,
um,
that alone,
just having that contest and given away
a tank.
Yeah.
And then putting together this video for
the tank at red band put together this
really cool video about it.
So these tank centers,
because we talking about it on the
podcast,
started opening up all over the world to
the point where now when you sign up at
a lot of tank centers,
the first time you go there they say,
how'd you hear about us?
Whether it was through the Internet,
through books or Joe Rogan,
like I'm one of their,
one of the,
I'm one of the options on a lot of their
questionnaires and that,
that probably has had even more of an
impact than,
than hunting.
Well,
it's,
you know,
it's amazing.
I,
I hear it all the time.
Well people have told me,
uh,
you wouldn't be anything without Joe
Rogan.
That's,
that's some comments that I've gotten.
Go again,
you're concentrating on the negative
ones.
I know,
but I wouldn't be bow on it if it wasn't
for you.
So there you go.
Well I wouldn't be me if it wasn't for
that.
I wouldn't be the me that I am now.
So there you go.
Okay.
Well I put it cause I was like,
God,
I know.
I don't know.
I think we've talked about it before,
but this podcast gets to more,
more people than CNN.
Is that right?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
So it's,
and I heard a Jordan Peterson talking
about we don lemon.
That's good.
Cause I,
I I trust this more than CNN.
CNN,
Oh,
you're a redneck.
You're on that Fox news tip.
Oh,
Fox News.
Now that's where you get your news solid
reporting.
That is legit.
That's Sean Hannity,
that guy.
I trust him with everything.
Yep,
I hear Ya.
But,
uh,
so,
and I heard Jordan,
you were talking about his recent
trajectory.
I mean,
he's been,
I,
I'm assuming you've been brilliant in
his whole life.
Well,
in the last 18 months or two years or
whatever.
And I think a lot of that is because of
here.
So I put in my phone,
I was like,
I'm going to do some research on Joe
Rogan before this.
I'm going to turn the tables on him,
I'm going to podcast him.
So I was like putting it in there,
Joe Rogan influence or Joe Rogan,
uh,
um,
a fact or whatever.
And uh,
I couldn't find anything.
So I think,
I think,
I think I need to write something to
quantify that,
but,
but yeah,
this gets to so many,
it gets so a lot of people,
but in all honesty,
like just being,
not,
not even just trying to be humble,
but all I'm doing is talking about shit
that's out there.
It's real simple.
It's like I'm not really doing anything
unusual other than that,
just being open minded,
which I try very hard to do.
I have,
when you say you just do this and just
do that,
nobody else does that.
They come in with these biases.
You know,
so you say that's a problem.
Yeah.
You say you just do that.
That's a big thing.
I think people need to stop doing that.
I think that's a big part of the problem
we have in this world.
And I was talking with,
uh,
Dan Harris from good morning America.
That's what he's on,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
and he was,
he used a word that,
I love a term that I love.
Toxic tribalism.
Yeah.
You know,
so I mean,
you see that with CNN versus Fox News.
It's like neither one of them want to
look at things subjectively.
Fox News has a very clear right wing
bias.
CNN has a very clear left wing bias and
they just go to war with each other.
Right.
And then the president's call and
everybody fake news and you know,
it's,
it's hard to,
to see what's really going on.
People want to look at their side,
they want to defend their side and they
never want to say,
okay,
I see this guy's point.
Yeah.
But you gotta be able to see people's
points.
I mean,
that's one thing that I always say about
vegans after I make fun of them.
I say I s I understand why you would
want to do that and I think it's a
compassionate choice.
I get it.
I totally understand.
But I do and I,
I support their decision.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it.
I think you should be real careful with
your health if you're doing that though.
And I'm not bullshitting.
This is not me being facetious or yeah,
I'm not being a meathead.
You should be careful with your health.
There's a lot of things that you should
probably check.
B 12 is a big one.
That's a huge issue with vegans is a,
b,
12 deficiencies.
And I think if you,
if you are a Vegan,
you should consider supplementing with
things that you don't have a problem
with eating.
Like maybe even some cricket protein or
mollusks like cell shelf.
If people should look into shellfish,
shellfish.
Not only is it are they sustainable,
but they're so primitive.
They don't even have like a,
a neurological system.
Like they don't feel any fucking pain.
Like,
you could eat clams all day long.
They don't know what the fuck is going
on.
This is,
we have this idea about clams because
they do that cause they close that
somehow now.
Oh,
the poor little thing is just trying to
hide like that,
that in there,
the oysters.
Oh,
okay.
I didn't know anything about it either.
I know about bow hunting.
Yes you do.
But to me,
um,
meat tastes better.
Yeah.
You feel better to know.
But as you were saying,
yeah,
I don't have a problem with vegans or
their diet or,
and I understand,
I mean,
you know,
if you think about,
um,
killing an animal,
nobody wants to kill animals.
Right?
I mean,
that's not,
I dunno,
that's never,
he didn't want to kill an animal for no
reason.
No.
You want the meat of the animal and
killing it and just not enjoyable.
You know,
it's,
it's part of the process.
Weird sense of loss,
right?
Yeah.
So I get that.
They're like,
well,
I don't want to,
I don't want to kill any animals.
I get it.
That's fine.
Yeah.
But yeah,
just having that,
you know,
the biases that come with it or is what
causes problems?
Well,
there they're doing what they think is
good to shame.
People who eat meat or attack people who
eat meat and especially attack people
actively go out and kill the animals
themselves because they think that
somehow or another it will lessen the
amount of animals that are killed.
I think the opposite happens.
I think it shores up people's aggression
towards vegans get it.
They,
they firmly plant their heels on the
other side of the line and they're like,
fuck you,
hippie [inaudible] asshole tree hug and
pitches.
Go eat your sprouts.
I'm going to go over here and eat
burger.
I mean,
there's a lot of people that go out and
eat burgers because of that.
Yeah.
I probably,
yeah.
No.
My friend Mike Hockridge from BC met
him.
Yeah.
Mike.
Mike was dealing with people from
Vancouver that were sending him hate
mail because of wolves now where he
lives.
He lives in the real British Columbia
where there's fucking while olds and
grizzly bears everywhere.
Yeah.
We found a a wolf kill while we were up
there.
It was pretty wild.
Wolf had got ahold of a moose calf.
It just tore it apart.
The pack of wolves,
they're all over the place and it,
it's pretty fresh too,
but he's shot a bunch of them and
somehow or another,
some group of people found out that he
shot wolves and where he lives,
you get an unlimited amount of wolf
tags,
right?
They're trying to kill wolves as much as
possible that you can kill a hundred
words a day if you can.
Then that's totally legal because they
have ranchers up there and like one of,
I think one of his neighbors,
they wolf,
it was a in the middle of the winter,
wolf got ahold of one of the cows and I
got a bunch of wolves,
a pack.
So these people are in their house.
They listened to a pack of wolves,
terror plot and cow that's like,
you know,
a hundred yards from their fucking bed.
Scary freaky shit.
Right?
They live in the real while.
So these people were sending him all
these death threats and so he said,
look,
every time you guys send me one of
these,
I'm going to shoot a wolf in the guts.
Yeah.
Radio silence.
They stopped.
Yeah.
He said to this lady,
he said,
every time you send me an email,
I'm going to shoot a wolf in the guts.
Yeah.
Well,
I dunno.
I was probably in front of a keyboard
going.
Yeah,
it's a tough one though.
That was a tough one.
Yeah.
You know the BC was,
they just outlawed grizzly hunting up
there because of that.
They did a poll in,
I think Vancouver,
and I'm not only that,
they did a very limited email poll with
about 3000 participants.
Right.
And 76% of 3000 people said that they
didn't,
they were opposed to grizzly bear
hunting.
But I think if you're going to have any
kind of a poll like that,
you should have to have these people
educated first as to what their voting
about.
Do you really understand what it's like
up there?
I know.
Cause if you talk to Mike,
Mike shot a grizzly bear in the head
from like 20 feet away as it was trying
to get into his cabin.
Like they are fucking ferocious and
they're huge and there's a lot of them.
There's no shortage of grizzly bears in
British Columbia now,
but it's that whole education piece.
But that's,
I mean,
you could take that to even voting in
our elections.
Sure.
I mean we need to educate people.
People need to be educated on the
topics,
not just hunting but everything.
But they can vote.
Their vote still counts.
Let's say you can't tell people they
can't vote because that's fucked up.
You can't,
well,
you have to
have a certain amount of education or
you can't vote.
But what they need to do is trust the
people who do now.
Yeah.
You know,
like up there,
the biologist who are actually have
boots on the ground or but,
and there are no,
the what grizzly are doing and how many
there are.
Let's go ahead and trust those people.
You know,
hard to see.
When you're in Vancouver though.
The problem is you're in Vancouver,
you're eating at a nice Sushi restaurant
and hanging out with friends.
You know,
he'd go into the movies.
Everything's beautiful.
Vancouver,
so nice.
So that you look at the mountains to
whistler off in the distance.
Oh,
that's so pretty.
Yeah.
I don't want to kill a bear.
Don't kill the best and now,
but if you just go on a six hour car
ride,
just go.
Just keep going north.
Keep going north and I you car and I
want you to go for a two mile hike into
the woods.
Just go for a two mile hike.
And I want you to sit there for a day.
Just sit there for a day.
You're going to see some shit.
Right?
And you will realize you will,
oh,
this is a different world.
This world is,
this is a wild world.
Like these things out here.
They don't give a shit if people are
real or not.
They are.
They're doing what they've always done.
The bear running around looking for shit
to eat,
the animals running around looking to
get the fuck away from things that are
trying to eat them.
And this is how they've always existed.
Yeah,
yeah,
I know.
And it's,
you know those bare and it's just like
the,
the wolves killing the cow.
You said 20 feet from the,
wherever they lived.
I mean,
that's just what they do.
But,
and that's what grizzlies do.
Grizzlies are going to kill.
They're can,
you know,
if they can kill a moose calf or an elk
cath or a deer fon,
they're not wasting a bunch of energy
chasing a full grown animal around.
So they're using less energy,
burning less calories.
They get an easy kill.
They get high protein.
That's just what they do.
But the reason why we need to kill them
is we're not,
they're never going to stop doing what
they do.
We just need to control the numbers.
So how often that's happening.
If that's happening too often,
because there's too many of them will
then the Moose and elk numbers go down,
you know,
and it's this balancing act and people
will say,
well,
I'm just let animals take care of
themselves.
They always have been and it's like,
no,
we've,
oh,
we've always hunted.
It's just now that people are saying,
well we shouldn't hunt.
You know,
so they're trying to take man out of the
equation.
Now.
Man's always been in the equation as far
as hunting.
Yeah.
I think people have an idea about it
based on the excess that people have
committed.
I mean,
people have committed some atrocities
when it comes to animals in this country
alone.
Everyone's seen those stacks of buffalo
heads.
And when they were doing market hunting
in particular in the 18 hundreds and ma,
many people attribute that to hunters,
um,
erroneous Lee.
That's not really what it was.
What killed off all those animals was a
thing called market hunting.
And this is back.
People have to realize there's no
refrigerators back then.
And so,
you know,
you weren't like getting steaks and
freezing them.
And there was not a lot of like large
scale agriculture back then either.
There's,
there was a few ranchers and farmers,
but when people had all these animals
that were out in the wild and they could
hire these people that were in the
military,
they had just gotten done
with the war and they were good shots.
They would,
this would be a good way to make a
living and go out there and shoot some
buffalo,
bring back the tongues buffalo and
tongue was like,
they would shoot a giant buffalo and
just take the tongue.
They'd take the hides and you know,
sometimes they would take the meat and
some and then they,
they wiped out almost everything.
They wiped out most of the deere,
most of the elk,
most of the antelope until guys like
Teddy Roosevelt came along well,
Whoa,
whoa,
hit the fucking brakes.
Like we've got to protect these animals.
We've got to protect this land.
We've got to protect these animals.
We got to set up private or public land
rather were will,
you can't do anything to it where people
could just roam and hike and camp.
And fish and hunt and do whatever you
want,
and we got to make sure we protect these
animal populations because they got down
to some incredibly low number of elk at
the turn of the century.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean they almost wiped out buffalo
completely.
I don't know what the hell got to,
but I know,
you know,
is as you know,
as conservationists,
we like to say that hunters are
conservationists now,
but so one of the figures that we share
is that there's more animals now than
there was a hundred years ago,
so I dunno know what they were a hundred
years ago,
what the numbers were.
But yeah,
very low.
Not only that,
there's more whitetail deer today than
when Columbus landed,
although Columbus road didn't really get
here when Columbus landed in The Bahamas
is more white tail deer here than now.
And part of that is because of farming,
which is real weird.
Like,
like a white tail deer is a weird
animal.
Yeah.
They're kind of a farm animal a lot of a
way.
Yeah,
it,
and it's almost like,
you know,
if you're doing it right as far as
killing the older bucks,
you're almost farming.
You know,
you're not harvesting when they're
young.
You're waiting till they're mature.
And so it's,
it's almost like,
you know,
you're letting that crop,
uh,
age essentially.
What does this Jamie,
in 1910,
the u s forest service estimated there
were only between 501,000 elk in
Colorado.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
And now there's a hundred and what?
25,000.
Oh,
150,000.
I don't know.
There was a fuck a lot more than that.
The numbers of fuckload.
There's 10 million.
Okay.
It says,
uh,
the elk population North America stood
at about 10 million animals before
European settlers came and systematic
wholesale hunting began.
Wow.
That's amazing.
[inaudible] Colorado became famous for
his trophy hunting and European
gentleman traveled here to try their
luck,
Sir George Gore.
I heard that guy was a con.
I'm just making that up.
He's a trophy hunter.
He's a trophy hunter for whom Gore pass
near.
Kremmling is named,
came from Ireland to hunt in western
Colorado.
He shot elk and deer from the bed of a
wagon.
What a Dick.
That's real honey.
He only took prime hides and large
antlers and left amit to rot a boy.
What a bad person.
That's that sentence right there.
And that's when people think happens
that I don't know anybody who ever does.
That's illegal.
First of all,
coaching.
Yeah,
that's a good thing.
The good thing to point out is illegal
to not take the meat rallies illegal.
To not take the mean,
you have to take the neck meet in
Colorado,
you have to cut out the neck,
all edible.
And you got all the edible meat.
And um,
and even between the ribs,
I mean there's a little,
I dunno about if that's a law in
Colorado.
I know in Alaska.
Yeah,
you killed a moose.
You,
you're even taking that meat in between
the ribs.
I mean,
you're taking all edible meat there.
And so people say,
well,
are you one of those trophy hunters?
Or you know,
you just don't take the head and leave
it to rot.
It's like,
you can't do that.
Why would you do that anyway?
It's so stupid,
but it's illegal anyway.
If you walked down the street,
if you,
if you eat steak and you walked down the
street and you saw like for some reason
someone had put coolers of prime rib
eyes,
it just sitting there,
you'd be like,
what the fuck is this here for?
Once we'd look around,
is there anybody here?
I've got to take this.
Yeah.
This can just leave this here.
Right,
so I have to do to rot,
so let's just do that.
When you're hunting,
that's just you finding it,
right?
Probably you would not eat it.
Now that I think about it,
you'd be like,
Whoa,
what is this a trap I get the point you
were making that when I was making is if
you go through all the effort to go hunt
and you do eat meat,
of course you're going to eat the meat.
Not only that,
the meat you're eating is incredibly
precious.
Yeah,
like elk meat is incredibly proud.
It's so delicious.
Oh,
here's,
here's what I know,
so when we go hunting,
and I can speak for myself,
I'm sure I can speak for you too.
For when you go hunting,
you bring back all the Mutu can you eat
all the Mutu Canada,
that animal you like sharing it that
typical,
I'll just say American,
but waste 40% of their food,
not,
I'm going to stop this.
What they buy.
You know how what I'm done now in the
garbage type thing,
so hunters,
I know I don't do that.
If I kill a bowl and I bring all that
meat home,
40% of that is not going in the garbage.
No.
You know what I mean?
So it's because we,
we are,
we have that connection with the animal.
To me it'd be,
I don't know if I'm thinking about it,
it'd be disrespectful,
but I just,
it's so it's worth,
those are so much value in it.
I would never throw it in the garbage,
you know what I mean?
But when you buy it at a store,
whatever,
you know,
I'm not saying people are putting,
40% of prime rib and the garbage,
but just as a rule,
we waste a lot of food.
I think it would be a good thing for
every single human being to grow some
vegetables.
And if you eat meat too,
once in your life,
kill an animal.
I think everyone should do it.
I really do.
There was an article that I tweeted
today about,
um,
that,
I forget the subject,
that title of it rather,
but it was something along the lines of
it's not,
it's not healthy to hide from the fact
that there's,
there's death involved in eating meat.
Right.
I did a terrible job of paraphrasing
that.
Fun.
What that title is.
So article.
Okay.
We shouldn't hide the gory details of
how meet reaches our plate.
Right.
What are the chickens?
Yeah.
And I think that's very,
very important.
And I think that like what I'm looking
at right there,
life is fucking gross.
That's her life.
Yeah.
It's fucked up.
Cause I eat chickens but I don't eat my
chickens.
Like someone said,
do you eat those chickens Mike?
Now there's like my pets.
It's weird.
Right.
But I'll,
I'll eat the shit out of some chicken.
Yeah.
But when you,
but when you think of it like that,
I mean,
so when we're,
we're looking at this picture,
I know people looking at or listening to
the podcast can't see the picture,
but I mean
we're looking at an enormous warehouse.
I mean enormous.
It looks like several football fields
long and it's filled with chickens that
are just stuffed on top of each other,
right?
Yeah.
And that's their life until they get
killed.
And when you think of that,
okay,
would I rather do that or would I rather
procure my own meat hunting?
You know,
everybody would say that's not right.
And I believe hunting is a noble way of
procuring me.
And um,
I think when you look at that,
but people don't see that.
They don't think about that when they
order their,
you know,
chick chicken nuggets.
They're not thinking about that.
No,
just hungry,
just hungry.
It's just too easy to get food mean.
I don't think it's too easy to get food.
That's why we're such fat toes.
That's a big problem.
But it's also just,
it's also too easy psychologically
because we just don't have any,
any connect.
I think you should have a connection if
you're eating a living thing just seems,
it just seems like you should understand
what it is.
Just for your own mind,
for you,
for your own,
for just a,
for a sense of balance.
And 97% of Americans eat meat,
meat and something like 65% of vegans
when they get drunk eat meat.
It really has some crazy number.
Some crate,
it might,
it might be higher than that.
I think I read it was like 84% of
vegans.
See,
I'm just making up numbers at this
point.
It's fine.
It doesn't mean it might've been a tweet
I read.
Somebody might have just made that up.
Just going to audit us.
So,
but so a Vegan drunk meets like an ex
girlfriend.
Yeah.
Right.
It's like an ex girlfriend.
Yeah.
So you get drunk if you're lonely,
you're taking risk and you're eating a
hot dog.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Same thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
Saying I got it.
Yeah.
It's a little over a third that
confessed to a eating meat when they're
drunk.
Oh,
well then it's 100% because three
quarters or more liars.
Yeah.
Surprising number of drug vegetarian
secretly meet.
That is an awesome picture right there.
The problem with this,
this thing is,
this is a third of people that they
asked British fit vegetarians.
Oh,
British people,
it's totally different animal.
They fucking hate hunters.
They love saying cunt.
Oh,
did I see,
did I say,
listen,
I think contin there.
I say that really?
I thought I'd do.
I've been looking phono flushing
out.
You said effing con we didn't say
fucking gun.
No,
that's the customer.
Yeah,
they do.
They do live to say con,
but they're,
they're the most delusional of there's
like South Americans.
There's no hunting.
Exactly.
No hunting.
Brazil for some strange reason.
I get a lot of hate from Brazil.
They love me.
You go to Brazil,
they invented that.
You husker IA.
Chu Has Korea's or this shit,
man.
Yeah.
Did we go to one or went Brazil?
Is that where they threw the plates in
the halls,
right.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
they threw the plate.
Yeah.
They fucking chuck fruit plates like
Frisbees and shatter them.
Yeah.
They know how to party in prison.
They do and it's just me on me.
On me.
You get a beautiful card.
It's got green on one side and red on
the other.
A lot of people have been to these like
a folder to chow is a great one that's
here in la and all over the country,
but that's what they ate.
They're famous for me.
When you're done with the meat,
you give him the red card.
Yeah.
Right?
It's green on one side and down the
other.
Yeah.
You tap out.
Yeah,
we go to town.
Nobody can fuck with Ari Shaffir.
When it comes to that place,
nobody really know.
I've never seen a look.
When me and Ari go to eat,
generally speaking,
I'm more of a glutton and him,
I'll eat more than him,
but not at that place really.
There's something about like all you can
eat.
I think maybe it's some like cause his
dad was in the Holocaust or something
like that.
Or He's just like,
because it's free because it's like you
could eat,
she just won't stop.
I've never seen anything like it.
I go like,
where are you putting all this fucking
food?
Everyone's done.
Joey Diaz has done.
I'm done.
Eddie Bravo is done.
We're done.
We're just sitting there like this.
Ah,
are you still John Green who's still in
green?
He's like,
I'm still on green.
Guy will come over and got lamb chops,
lamb chops.
She has to bring the lamb chops.
God,
I can't,
I've never seen,
especially in Brazil,
they're all,
they know how to do it and they have
grass fed meat over there too.
They're not fucking around with the corn
fed and all that.
They don't have the sick fat cows that
we have over here.
But it is weird how you get a lot of
hate from people over there,
but it's because of the propaganda and
the,
the negative aspects of trophy hunting.
Like when you see a guy standing there
with a dead elephant or some shit like
that,
like,
wow,
fuck,
would you kill an elephant?
Like that kind of stuff in people's mind
like,
or a giraffe.
Why the fuck would you kill a giraffe?
Like people have this idea that these
people just go over there to kill
things.
And so this is what trophy hunting is.
So they see you with an elk,
like,
oh,
you piece of shit.
Why are you just go over there and shoot
that thing?
Like,
yeah,
no,
this is my food for a year.
Like you're,
you're going to that Goddamn steakhouse
and you keep that thing on green.
What do you think you're doing?
You're killing,
killing with your credit card.
And now it's a,
well,
all we can do is try to educate and
share the sh,
share the lifestyle.
It's like,
I think it's important,
um,
to be leaders and,
and how we share that,
you know,
cause I see things that I wish weren't
shared sometimes.
I mean,
I've,
I've even made mistakes.
I'm not trying to say that I got,
I'm dialed in and I never make them a
shit mistake on what I post or whatever.
But,
um,
I just think we need to be stewards of
hunting and,
and if we do it right,
we're not going to get everybody and
we're not going to educate everybody
because there's some that just won't
listen.
Um,
but we can make some inroads.
I think we have,
and I think,
um,
I think it's important to relay
experience.
It says,
because I think there's,
there's,
there's things to be learned from a lot
of experiences,
you know,
like talking to you and talking to
Courtney Galt,
doe Walter about just ultra marathons
and endurance running.
There's something to be learned from
that about the kind of mindset that it
takes to do that.
I think having these conversations with
you guys has changed the way I look at
those things.
Like,
fuck man,
for,
I'd met you.
I never ran.
I'm running all the time now.
I run all the time.
You look slow.
I've been have you,
how much you weigh?
One 96.
[inaudible] 95 the same.
No,
I'm a little lighter or it was up to
like two oh four when I was a fat so.
Oh okay.
That was the fastest I've ever been
thought you look slimmer.
I'm a little maybe a little slimmer
maybe I'm like one 95 or one 91 94 is
when I'm pretty lean.
We've got a full six pack.
Look at one 94 when I hit about two,
when I get to 200 that's when I start.
I go,
okay,
we better start doing the fasting again.
Yeah.
When I really get into my intermittent
fasting,
I'll spend either 14 or 16 hours without
eating in a day.
I want to eat for like 10 hours in a
day.
Yeah.
I eat about every 30 minutes.
I'm actually starving.
How you starting right now?
Now you're in a different thing though.
Cause I'm,
I'm eating mostly fat and you know a lot
of guys are on that carnivore diet.
Now when we had that Sean Baker in here,
that doctor,
the,
the bells,
Chris Bell and Mark Bell and those guys
are both on the carnivore diet.
Now they don't need anything but meat
all day.
Wow.
Yeah.
Mark said he's never felt better.
So just to thin it looks ripped.
If you look at his instagram page,
he's fucking jacked.
Shredded.
It's also on steroids that they're
probably helps but,
but he looks good.
Yeah.
Well it's uh,
I dunno.
I,
one of my favorites,
she picks up because Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Look at him.
Look at that picture.
Oh my is meat while he's eating his meat
jacked.
Yeah.
Jack,
Stan plus steroids.
A little bit starts.
Right.
But whatever he's at Mark Bell.
Yeah.
He's a fucking animal.
Then I watched the bigger,
stronger,
faster.
Is that what it was?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was his,
his brother was on there.
Right.
Three brothers and one of them died of
them.
Died.
They hit a drug problem.
He was a pro wrestler.
Yeah,
that's the one I watched as it.
Yeah.
It was a powerful document was,
and it was,
it was pretty sad.
I mean,
he wanted,
you know,
his brother wanted to make it be
something.
It's just like a lot us,
you know,
and you know,
it's hard to say.
Well,
he ran into the problem that I've seen
many people run into those goddamn
prescription pills.
They're so scary.
They are.
They're one of the scariest things that
are in modern society.
And it's something that's not talked
about enough.
You only hear it talked about from
family members of people that have lost.
People are close friends and people that
have lost people.
But it's a,
it's a giant problem in this country.
We're losing thousands of people every
day too.
Pain pills.
Yeah.
Well I,
you know,
I put something up not long ago about
suicide and it was amazing how many
people sent me messages.
I mean,
how many people are affected or just are
dealing with negative thoughts of their
own and then a little mini battles and
it's just like that one post.
I don't know.
I think people just need to know that
there's people out there that care,
you know?
But I don't know how with,
when they get into that cycle of pills,
I don't really know.
I'm not a doctor.
I don't know how that works.
I don't know what they're dealing with.
I just know that,
you know,
social media can be used.
It can be irritating sometimes,
but man,
it can be good,
especially for people like that.
She's able to reach out and maybe,
you know,
get some support or encouragement or
something,
you know?
And it's
well for someone that they admire,
like you,
that's gigantic,
you know,
if they can,
they can read something like that.
Sometimes that's all people need.
Just a little wind in their sail.
Just a little something.
So something I'm gonna say I dorm thing,
I'll,
I say,
you know,
it was,
it was in the news.
There's a quarterback up at Washington
state that killed himself.
You know,
he's going to be the starting
quarterback on the football team,
21 years old.
And he shot himself a few weeks ago.
And I didn't want,
I didn't want to say that well,
because I don't want to say that.
Well,
it's because it's an athlete.
That's why anybody cares,
you know?
But it's anybody,
it's any person who's 21 years old.
I'm thinking what a tragedy that is.
But it just,
that was in the new,
so it happened.
And so that's why I put it up and for
no,
or I can't do anything.
It's not like I'm,
I don't,
I'm,
I just want people to be aware and just
to have that number to call.
And the case,
there was a 21 year old feeling that
exact same way and there's this
seemingly some kid who had everything.
I mean the co a college quarterback and
it's just like,
it just breaks my heart to think that
they would get to,
that he would get to that point where,
you know,
killing himself was the answer.
And it's just harder for younger people
because they don't have,
I have a
lot of life experiences and they don't
know that like a guy like you or I who's
lived a long time and I've seen a lot of
shit that you've gone through your ups
and downs and when you hit it down you
go,
well this sucks,
but I know it's going to get better.
Yeah,
just got to figure out why it sucks.
Address why it sucks.
Uh,
apologize if you need to correct
whatever the issue is that's making you
feel like shit.
Pull yourself out of it,
do a bunch of positive things.
Next thing you know you're going to be
okay again.
Yeah,
and sometimes when you're 21 years old,
you do,
you think the world's over.
You know?
I mean,
I remember when my girlfriend dumped me
when I was 18 I was so fucking bummed
out.
I couldn't imagine.
I couldn't imagine living without her.
I was like,
I can't believe that this is over.
I can't put you so devastated cause
you're fucking Europe baby.
18 year old baby.
You don't know Jack Shit.
But when you get older and you've had
more life experiences and more things,
you get more perspective and you kind of
understand like what this feeling is bad
feeling and you just know,
well,
hey,
I just gotta get the fuck out of the
house.
I've got to go hang out with my friends,
got to go do a bunch of positive things.
Go hit the gym,
take a yoga class,
do something fun,
and then everything's going to be okay.
You realize,
hey,
you know,
life's not perfect.
There's no such thing as a perfect life.
It doesn't exist.
You're going to have ups,
you're going to have downs.
But when you're 21 years old,
it's very difficult to see that.
And also who knows what else was going
on in his life,
whether it was pills or whether it's a
head trauma.
And a lot of football players wind up
killing themselves.
It's not a coincidence.
It's directly related to head drama.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not sure.
I don't want to speculate.
I don't eat that.
It's just,
uh,
I just,
you know,
it's horrible.
I get a lot of,
I just,
when you said,
well you go hang out with your friends,
it sometimes,
cause I've been in certain groups where
even my friends aren't positive,
you know what I mean?
So you're like,
that even makes it worse.
They can.
So I mean,
that's where I see the positives of
social media and I wish I could respond
to everybody who sends me a message and
just say,
Hey,
you know,
and it's,
it's Cliche,
keep hammering or whatever.
But I know,
I know I get inspiration from people
online and if,
um,
I get a shout out,
it feels good.
It doesn't mean anything.
Where's your t shirt?
It doesn't mean,
I don't know if it means it doesn't mean
anything but eat some.
But it does to me,
you know?
And so I just know what it's like to be
in a small town and to not,
I'm not saying I didn't have any
positive friends or whatever,
but I would know what it feel like to
not have anybody to really lean on,
you know?
Yeah.
And so I tried to think about maybe
people like I was and a man.
I just think we can,
I dunno together Shit we can,
we can do a lot of positive things.
I just,
it just,
like I said,
it breaks my heart to think of people.
Um,
living negative.
Yeah.
Each day.
I agree with you.
And I think that's one of the things
that social media can do that's positive
and also podcasts can do that's positive
is it exposes you.
Like there's people that are listening
to this conversation right now that
they're taking comfort from it.
Like they might be either stuck in a
shitty job or they might be alone and
they're here with us.
They're here hanging out and they
realize those people like us out there.
This is friendly,
positive people out there.
Even if you're alone,
at least you're not around negative
twats,
right?
You know,
there's a lot of negative people around
and it's unfortunate that they're
negative.
I wish you could fix them all,
but sometimes life gives you these
lessons in the form of disastrous lives
that you witness and you see these
disasters lives and you just go,
oh my God,
I gotta get the fuck away from this
crazy ass hole and live my life in a
more positive,
productive way because I see what can
happen if you blame the world for all
your problems and you,
all you do is hate and you hate on
people that are successful and you hate
on people that are whatever wealthy,
good looking,
whatever the fic pick,
pick the thing.
Girls that are thin,
whatever the thing is that you hate on,
there's so many people out there that
waste all of their energy doing that.
And if you're around them,
you can't fix them.
It's so hard to fix people.
But what you can do is see what they're
doing that's so negative and just
completely degrade the quality of their
life and just don't do that.
Recognize,
recognize that this is not the way to
live.
And then go listen to a podcast with
some positive people and say,
look at this guy.
This guy's out there eating healthy,
doing good things.
He lost 15 pounds.
She went running and just decided to
start doing marathons and he did this
and this guy's building a fucking house.
Like you can.
You can find a lot of positive examples
of people online today.
That's,
that's one of the reasons why I'm so
drawn to ultra running.
I mean,
because whether you like running or not,
the people that do that are some great
positive people.
I mean,
they're savages.
Oh.
But they're also,
you get so use of winning those many
battles in the long run.
And you,
I mean,
you have to and you get strength from
each other.
So at the finish line or during the race
is you can get a bond.
Um,
there's a saying,
you know,
he sheds his blood with me,
will be my brother.
And it's like,
it's not,
that's probably derive from war and,
and I get that.
And it's not like a war or anything like
that,
but it's going through a mini battle.
And when you do that with somebody and
you share that experience,
you get that connection.
And it's like,
it's why even though I don't know
courtney that well,
um,
I know what she does and I really look
up to her ability to just be a beast and
that whole environment,
the ultra running environment and
community is a,
is empowering for me for sure.
And,
and that's,
that's why I love even just being around
people like that,
it just makes you better.
Well,
they're,
they're exceptional.
Yeah.
Those are exceptional people there.
They have an exceptional mind to be able
to endure something like a 238 mile race
through the Moab desert.
You've got to be something special.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a little thing in the back of
has,
has want to just sit down,
lunches,
quit.
I says,
enough's enough.
We're already ran five miles.
Where do you want it?
This is enough,
man.
You ran a marathon.
I isn't enough.
You had two marathons.
So you sit the fuck down.
We just sit the fuck down and take a
nap.
But you have to be able to shut off and
most people
can't shut that off.
Can't,
you know,
it's,
it's tough.
It's,
it's amazing.
I mean,
um,
my brother was with me on that last one
and uh,
and it's,
and it's weird to share,
uh,
an experience like that with somebody
because you can be similar,
but in the course of something at three
days like that,
you're in low points at different times,
you know what I mean?
And so it's really hard.
It's really hard to win each of those
battles because at one time when you
might,
I dunno,
it's just,
it seems like that'd be easier.
But I think in,
in some respects it is,
but it's,
man,
it does,
it's tough.
It was tough all the way around.
So when you're going through a three
day,
238 mile run does it,
it,
it gets bad at certain times where you
just feel like shit and then if you keep
going it gets better and then it gets
bad again.
Yeah.
And then it gets better.
Oh yeah.
You're up and down,
up and down the whole time.
And,
but you know that if you keep going,
even when you feel like dog shit,
you'll eventually break through and
start feeling okay again.
I don't know.
There's no guarantee.
No,
there's no you hope.
Have you ever gone through a whole long
race and felt like dog shit the entire
time?
Yeah.
Which one of those?
Uh,
well like the 24 hour run,
you know,
cause that's usually like my first tough
one of the years in June.
So I haven't really prepared for it.
And now,
cause I'm always after spring bear and
uh,
I haven't been training because I've
been up in bear camp and doing whatever.
So that's always one where I know I'm
just pretty much going to be miserable
the whole time.
There's going to be no light at the end
of the tunnel,
other than one of the 24 hours is up.
So that one,
I know I'm just going to have to grind
it out.
But,
and that's,
that's where I'm like [inaudible] it's
a,
this is one day out of my life,
just do it.
I'm just going to be miserable.
Um,
you know,
on,
on Moab,
that one started off and I felt terrible
right out of the,
I mean I felt,
I was like,
we were God don't want to think like 19
or maybe 15 miles in something like
that.
An aid station.
I'm going,
this is not good cause teen miles in.
It's crazy as you were running a
marathon a day.
Yeah.
So why was 15 miles so bad?
Um,
I dunno.
There's sometimes when you,
do you ever go on a run and your legs
just feel heavy and he just don't feel
good?
Yeah.
So that's what that,
I just,
I was like,
I wanted to be fresh and I want it to
feel light on my feet and I want to get
out there.
And I was like,
it's not a good sign when I didn't,
because,
you know,
we just essentially started the race and
it was hot and I had run out of water
already one time.
And,
um,
my legs felt heavy.
And so it was a,
it wasn't looking good.
And then courtney was way out ahead and
you know,
they're saying I,
with,
I didn't really know who she was at that
time.
So we were,
me and my brother Taylor,
we were thinking we'll 70 in the 70s
would win the race.
So I thought,
well,
I want to go out and,
and aim for finishing in the 70s.
And when you say seventies,
what do you mean,
70 hours?
Yeah.
So I figured,
because what usually one big foot was
high sixties in big foot's two oh five
two oh five.
And so this is,
you know,
close to 35 miles further.
So we just figured,
well,
probably seventies is going to get it
done.
And so she went out and she had,
there's an under a couple of other guys
with,
or I think,
and they went out pretty hard.
And,
uh,
you know,
there's updates and where they were.
And I didn't know,
I didn't know at that time she was the
American record holder for the hundred
20 or the 24 hour run.
She'd run 160 miles I think in 24 hours
this Christ.
And so I was like,
oh well they just went too fast.
You know,
cause I had done that before and like a
big foot the year before and I thought,
well they'll come back,
you know,
so meaning it'll balance out.
We'd catch up or they come back.
And uh,
I think the guys with her ended up
dropping off a little bit and then she
never came back.
She just,
well one of them dropped out,
totally tried to keep up with her and he
couldn't.
Then he wound up dropping out.
Totally.
She's a monster and she's eating Nachos
and candy.
That was crazy.
Drinking beer.
Well,
all these people are on like all these
diets watching their macro nutrients
and,
no,
but I didn't want to say that is cause
that,
cause I listened to you talk to her
about that and excuse me,
I've seen a lot of comments about that.
But what you got to keep in mind is the,
her training.
So you can't say,
well I run 15 miles a week and I'm going
to eat Nachos and beer.
Right.
So she's running 120 miles a week.
Probably you can eat pretty much
whatever you want.
So I get that.
But it's also like I was asking her
about like the nutritional content of
our food.
You really monitoring how much protein
you get versus Fido nutrients and
minerals.
No,
no.
She's gotten it out.
She probably just needs calories,
you know,
she just,
it doesn't matter.
It didn't matter what,
how she gets them just needs calories to
sustain herself.
Just think for just a,
the cells of your body,
you would need more nutrients.
I mean who knows?
She's obviously a fucking savage.
Yeah.
But who knows if she really monitored
her diet and ate super healthy,
she might be better maybe,
which is just terrifying maybe.
Yeah,
she's,
she's amazing.
She's so normal to me.
Hang out with her.
Like when she did the podcast,
she's just fun and laugh and look,
you would never imagine that Jesus like
elite ultra marathon runner,
I would think you'd have to be like
super stoic and intense and just,
and when you see her she's wearing like,
it looks like basketball shorts.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah,
exactly.
Shorts.
It's not like,
you know,
you see some of these track athletes and
they got the tight little shorts on and
the,
and the singlet and they're like,
you know,
she does like it with a kind of a baggy
shirt and baggy shorts and then just
crushing people.
Crazy.
Yeah.
She's,
but I love that though.
I love outliers.
A lot of people that come along with
don't make any sense.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Like did she so much better than
everybody else?
She won that 238 mile race by 22 miles,
something like that.
Yeah,
22 miles ahead of the second place
winner.
And the guy who got second is this done
fucking animal has done as an animal.
She was 22 miles ahead of him.
Now imagine get whupped not just
whooped,
but what 22 miles ahead by someone was
eating Nachos and drink beer and eat
candy.
I love that.
I love someone that doesn't make any
sense,
who is just so much better.
It's just like,
wow,
we got to fucking throw the,
throw a monkey wrench into this whole
idea.
The only thing I got on anybody is can
they pack out an elk there?
You got to,
you got to sit on them.
You know,
if that was the race,
you'd fuck them all up.
But what I like about her also is I flew
home the other day,
I can't remember where it was from,
but I flew over like there's some in the
cascades of Oregon,
there's a middle sister,
north sister,
south sister,
and then bachelor's where everybody goes
and skis and then broken tops right
there.
So I filmed it and I'm like,
I tagged my brother Taylor and I'm like,
Hey,
can we knock off all five of these peaks
in 24 hours?
And uh,
and it would be,
I mean,
it would be a test,
you know,
and she commented and said she wants to,
she joined us,
she wants to come do it.
So I mean,
I just love that.
I don't,
I don't even,
she's a,
she's amazing.
But that type of,
I mean,
I guess I kind of goes hand in hand with
the eating.
Whatever you want is also doing whatever
you want.
You know,
like a lot of these elite athletes,
they,
they would be like,
have a schedule of races and my training
and this and that and I,
you know,
whatever.
I like that she's would just say,
yeah,
I'll do that.
Yeah.
It's not a race,
it's just we're just having fun.
Yeah.
Or just a test.
It's a,
it's an unofficial test and to,
for her to want to join in.
That's probably what I love the most
about her and I are there established
trails that you guys could run over all
those peaks.
Um,
we did the south sister in the middle
sister last year and now it's uh,
getting off the south sister towards the
middle sister is sketchy.
It's,
there's no trails.
No.
Oh,
so you just run it through the woods?
It's on the side.
There's no trees.
It's all inside of a mountain.
So it's like a shale and oh,
even more sketchy.
Yeah.
I'd rather run over trees yet.
Sort of now you would because you know
if there's trees are there solid ground
there.
Right.
You know,
so with,
with the rocks up there,
you don't know what's going to happen,
but you got to be stepping over shit.
If there's trees there,
you might want it to a bunch of places
where all the trees have fallen down
generally.
Yeah.
I mean there can be a windfall in there,
but generally you can get on animal
trail and find your way through,
you know,
but when it's just rocks,
that's what,
that's probably the most sketchy cause.
Yeah.
Cause just because there's a,
you know,
I don't know,
a thousand pound rock sitting there,
it could just just be balanced
perfectly.
You might step on it.
That could be,
there's no guarantee that those rocks
are staying there,
you know,
falls all the time.
So that's with rocks and that type of
country,
super steep.
It's a,
as part of it,
it's fascinating to me that that is the
appeal of sheep hunting too,
a lot of people is that it's so
incredibly dangerous that being up in
those high peaks and stepping on shale,
like on these,
these crazy peaks where to the left is
just a,
a steep drop off to the right is a steep
drop off and you have a very narrow
place to navigate.
Yeah.
It's uh,
you know,
she punning they say it's not the,
it's not the animal that's the most
wary.
It's just the country that makes it so,
I mean,
they're expensive that the hunts,
but it was just what they did to that.
It's just where they live is the draw,
you know,
there,
I think with the bow,
definitely a tough animal with a rifle.
Mostly it's just kind of getting in.
If you can get your body within a range,
you know,
you can usually get one done.
But it's,
it's just where they live.
Yeah.
When,
um,
Ben O'Brien and a green tree,
we're hunting tar.
Yeah.
Similar thing New Zealand.
Then these crazy peaks and super
dangerous sketchy territory and people,
it's fascinating to me how people get
addicted to incredibly difficult things.
They do it.
They say,
fuck,
I'm never doing this again because it's
terrible.
And then they get back in a couple of
weeks later,
they're like,
shit,
I don't want to go back.
Yeah.
It's a god.
I don't know what,
I don't know what type of analogy to
make,
but um,
you know,
if you,
when you've done say maybe ultras are
marathons,
it's really hard to get excited for a
five k,
you know what I mean?
When you do your key Pam and five k,
how boring is that for you?
Uh,
I,
to me this is more about the people
then.
Yeah.
It's not for me.
I'm not that stupid.
Race is the reason why I got started
running.
I couldn't believe how hard it was to do
with zero running folks.
Zero.
I ran zero and then I ran a five k.
Yeah.
And at the end of that I was like,
okay,
I gotta start running shit.
Yeah.
And it feels great now,
right?
Yes it does.
There's nothing,
nothing that feels better to me than
being older run.
I mean,
you know what's crazy is my endurance
for kickboxing is way better.
Yeah.
I mean way better.
Way Better.
Like I could do a hard three minute
round.
No problem.
Yeah.
And it's just from running these fucking
hills changes your lung capacity.
Yeah.
Your lungs just expand and then contract
and you just used to get any more oxygen
in there,
I guess.
Yeah.
Well still it's true.
You've seen those trails that I'm
running on to.
It's so,
they're so steep.
It's so much of it is just pushing,
pushing,
pushing.
It's like you're sprinting up these
hills and you're,
your body's just used to those bursts,
you know?
And so now when I go crazy on the heavy
bag,
I buy,
buy,
boom.
And then the bell would go off and I'm
like,
oh good.
It's crazy.
Like it's amazing.
It's,
and it does so much for your legs to Oh
yeah.
People always ask me,
you know,
what I do for legs?
And it's like I just run mountains.
I mean,
and it's,
you know,
yeah.
There was a famous kickboxer from
Montreal,
his name was John Eve terrio.
He was like the most scary kickboxer in
the world in the PKA karate days.
And uh,
all he did was he would run stairs.
Like that was the,
the big workout that he ran.
He wrote a book on training and uh,
you know what it takes to be a world
champion.
And one of the things that he's saying
is you got to run stairs.
He's like running stairs.
He's like,
have been the best thing for his kicking
power for his endurance,
for the,
I remember thinking that.
And you're just talking about how just
put inches on his thighs and it's just,
it radically increased his lung capacity
and kicking power.
Speaking of,
uh,
endurance,
I dunno if we were,
but I will.
But Francis and Ghana,
he got gassed out.
He did well.
He tried to take steep pay out in the
first round.
He,
that was his,
his thought was that steep pace,
not going to be a survivor.
Didn't happen.
It's not good.
It's fucked.
Yeah.
And he doesn't know how to wrestle that.
Well.
He's doesn't have,
he doesn't have a long background in,
uh,
in martial arts at all.
And Steve Bay was a very good college
wrestler and obviously a bad
motherfucker,
you know,
he took some hard shots to,
he did.
You know,
that's the thing about Steve paid.
It's not just that he knows how to
fight,
it's,
he's just fucking tough.
It's just,
there's a bunch of shit going on there.
It's experience.
It's just sheer toughness and grit and
determination.
And he also,
he knows how to ride out bad moments.
Like Francis had never had a bad moment.
Right.
He didn't know what the fuck to do.
I think most people,
I know you,
you,
you didn't,
but I think most people had kind of
assumed,
oh,
Frances is gonna win this fight.
I thought it's very possible.
Francis could win.
The fight.
I thought it was very possible that
Francis could just newcomb in the first
round.
He's just so scary.
Yeah.
It just takes one.
No,
I've never seen anyone in all of my
history of watching mma.
That's so terrifying with one punch.
Yeah.
And he's just punching to this kicks or
you know,
they're okay.
He's not,
but he's not like a,
you know,
he's not Edson Barboza or someone who
could put you to sleep with one kick.
He's not kicking people.
He's just moving towards you throwing a
few kicks maybe.
But what he's trying to do is hit you
with those giant fucking canned hams
that he calls his fists.
And even when he was so gassed,
he could barely do anything.
I was taking up,
just taste still one big tired heavy arm
could do it.
Oh yeah.
100% that guy still has unbelievable
potential if he could get it together.
But when he needs to do,
and this is critical,
he needs to work on his ground game,
needs to work on his wrestling and he
needs to be with a real top flight mma
camp who's trains him now he trains with
the guy who found him.
Um,
I forgot the gentleman's name,
but uh,
the guy's done an amazing job of
building his skills up and you know,
in five years.
And the thing is Frances is so goddamn
good that most people,
he spars with most people,
he fights with our fucked,
when buddy runs the top of the food
chain and got like Steve Bay,
Steve Bay can avoid all the dangerous
stuff,
drag them into deep water,
get his,
get him diminished,
diminishes his endurance and his ability
and then overwhelm them,
which is what Steve Bay did.
Yeah.
But Francis can learn from that.
He can learn from that.
He can learn from that and he can get
better at all those areas that he had
problems with.
Tired.
Yeah.
But he can get the endurance is
something you can work on.
You can work on all those things.
I just don't know how.
I'm sure he worked hard.
I'm absolutely sure,
but I don't know how hard he was pushed.
So there's a difference between working
hard and being pushed,
right?
Like if you,
if he's trained with a guy like Cain
Velasquez,
for instance,
prime time,
Cain Velasquez,
if keynes in his prime,
Kate's taking him down left and right,
he's going to try to have to get up all
the time.
He's doing rounds of cane.
You're going through how you get through
five minutes of hell,
and when that bell goes off to it to end
the five minutes of hell,
you're just like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
You know,
you've watched the,
the,
the training camps with Daniel Cormier
and Luke rockhold and Cain Velasquez,
some of the footage.
There's a reason why those guys are so
God damn good because iron sharpens
iron.
It's right.
Those guys are in their world champions
going at it with each other on a daily
basis and because of that,
that's what turned them into those
fucking monsters they are today.
Yeah.
Frances is just a physical freak.
But if he was in that camp,
whole leash shit.
Yeah,
that'd be,
that'd be amazing.
It'd be amazing to see what,
what he could do.
Yeah.
I don't know.
The problem is sparring with that guy.
Like if you're,
if Francis spars,
the way they spar because dcs,
they go hard.
Don't go.
They go a little hard.
Isn't that kind of maybe too hard?
That's the argument.
Just two arguments.
There's one argument is that they're
going through that is why they're so
successful in world championship fights
that they know what to buy.
They know what the fire feels like.
Yeah.
The other thing is that they're also
increase their,
they get injured a lot.
Yeah.
That camp gets injured a lot,
but it's also,
there are so fucking good.
Who could,
they got hubby.
You've never come at off Luke rockhold
Daniel Cormier Day
cane,
motherfucking Velasquez.
It's not,
you can't argue with that one camp in
San Jose.
That's because some of the best fighters
that have ever done the sport.
Then on top of that,
Josh Thompson,
you know,
they had Josh Koscheck for a while and
he was at the top of his game.
Some fucking killers have come from Aka,
so you could look at it two ways.
You could say one,
they're beating each other up too much
or too,
that's what you gotta do.
You gotta do to be a world champion.
It's uh,
it's hard to say.
I mean,
I was still to this day when Kane was in
his prime,
I never saw a heavyweight like that
before ever.
The fucking endurance that guy had was
off the charts.
It's not like nothing.
You would see guys just should be
overwhelmed.
They couldn't imagine how the fuck he
could do this.
Like where's he getting his second round
would come around and have this look on
their face and cain would just be like,
like you just woke up.
Like he's not even,
he's not even starting to really sweat.
Yeah.
Beat the shit out him for the second
round.
Pete,
the shit on for the,
they would just wilt under the pressure.
Yeah.
You see those fights where,
I mean not,
not him,
but I mean even now or,
uh,
it's just an onslaught and you're just
like,
man,
you feel bad for well that,
that uh,
who was at the other night,
uh,
Chanko that did you see that fine.
He's just quiet.
I was like,
can this fight get over?
Because they should have stopped that
fight a long time.
Moodle.
I should have been stopped 15 or 20
times.
Oh my God.
It was brutal.
Yeah.
Mario Yamasaki said he gave her the
opportunity to be a warrior.
That's what he said.
That was his,
his take on it.
Oh Man.
I mean he was getting beat up,
not just beat up the,
did you see the stats,
the actual physical striking stats,
the significant strikes.
Did she land any one?
Okay.
And Valentine,
she landed one like,
I think it was some unbelievably
overwhelming number.
Like one versus several hundred in the
significant strike department.
Like literally shit.
Mike landed one pretty decent punch
shift.
Chank goes,
she looked like a guy up there with a
big heart,
elbows,
you know,
come into,
I mean,
just like just power guy.
Sexist much.
Someone's a fucking sexist.
Did you notice that Jamie?
Oh Jesus.
That's world champion Moy.
Tai kickbox.
Well it looks like a world champion
woman.
You son of a bitch.
I'm getting,
I'm getting read the riot act over here.
You gotta be careful these days.
People turn on you.
I hate that.
That,
that really irritates me.
Oh,
I think I'm going.
Yeah.
Why is it wrong to say she looks like a
guy?
I don't know.
She's a woman.
You son of a bitch.
That's why I would just talking more
about the power.
Okay.
You just don't see women.
Um,
you know the strikes 95 to two.
Oh,
but you can still see women like coming
down hard like that.
Have you before?
Um,
yeah.
Cotsen Guano
cats and dogs can do that when they're
on that,
that,
that top position and just raining part.
It's just like,
I just haven't seen it that often.
No,
it's,
there's not a lot of women that can
throw down like that.
And I've,
Valentino is one of the most well
rounded women in the sport.
She's,
yeah,
she subbed Julianna Pena off her back.
She,
you know,
she stands up and out strikes holiday
home.
She went toe to toe with a Amanda Nunez.
She went toe to toe with some of the
best kick boxers in the worst.
She's a world champion,
Moy Thai fighter,
and she's just a fucking beast man.
Yeah.
All around just bad bad ass fighter.
There was an argument that she won that
the,
for the championship against doing is
super close fight.
I didn't think it was a bad decision,
but I thought it was a,
it was a very close fight.
Yeah.
It's hard,
you know,
and it's hard for me calling fights
because of I'm calling them,
I'm just looking at what's happening.
I'm trying to talk,
but I'm not scoring it,
you know,
I don't score it.
Score it.
You gotta keep your mouth shut and you
should have a piece of paper in front of
you.
And you know,
Eddie Bravo used to do it.
Uh,
for the UFC,
he used to score in between rounds and
he had a great system where he would put
a line down the center of a paper and
it'd be like one opponent on the left
side and the other one on the right
side.
And then he would write down like kicks
takedowns submission attempts and all
that stuff.
And then defense,
those are little categories.
And they would put checkmarks Hash marks
to one.
Yeah.
And then he would go over why he thought
someone won and what kind of score he
get.
He had a very good system and I think
that's the only way to fairly judge a
fight.
Right.
When your class,
it's like Valentino Shift Gencos fight
where you just go like,
what the fuck?
I gave her like 10 to two.
I mean it was,
it wasn't so overwhelming.
I mean,
yeah,
a 10,
eight round is a disgrace.
It's like a 10,
six or if you gave it just a 10,
eight,
you'd be like,
who the fuck are you?
[inaudible] Shit,
judge you God,
that was crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
um,
it was a bad matchup because that girl
was there,
I believe that was her ufc debut.
So to have a UFC debut against a woman
who has fought for the title against a
world class striker,
I mean literally one of the very best
strikers on the planet earth,
male or female and just on,
it's not fair.
You know,
that was her first fight at one 25,
wasn't it?
Valentina's yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
Valentine fought,
uh,
you want to,
you and Jay check in Moitai Thai and uh,
so she beat her.
Hmm.
Um,
I think,
I think they fought more than once,
but I believe Valentino beater.
I hope I'm not wrong because I'm around
a lot.
I'm excited for that arose.
Uh,
now in unison you want to and Jay check
where you met.
Yeah.
Well,
you know rose trains with Valentino.
Oh,
that's her main sparring.
really?
Yeah.
That's a good camp.
Then just those having those
two there dough to work off each other.
Yeah.
Phenomenal.
For rose and for Valentino,
it's going to be tough for rose to come
now as the champion.
I don't know.
It'd be interesting to see how if it
changes at all.
Oh yeah.
It will definitely be interesting and
coming into this fight,
what's fascinating to me,
even though rose one by first round
knockout,
she's the the underdog.
Yeah.
Well it's,
I put up that clip of it when she was
like saying the Lord's prayer there.
When you're up there in years talking
about how it was terrifying or something
like that.
I put up that little quip.
It was,
that was crazy.
Oh,
he's no one is from you guys.
Yeah.
Before on fight night before the fight,
you guys were standing there and there.
They're showing that from the way in and
Oh my God,
that was classic.
Yeah.
She was so in the zone that you wanna
was talking shit to where you're going
to fuck you up.
I'm going to fuck up your bogey.
I'm boogie woman.
She's talking all this crazy shit to her
and rose just going,
our father who art in heaven,
I won't be that name.
Thy Kingdom come,
thy will be done.
And she was like in this zone where you
want to put her fist on her nose.
And she didn't even flinch.
That was the only one that,
and I said because they had something
off about fighter of the year I think.
But that was,
I get fired up for all the fights,
but that was the only fight that I was
standing up.
Like I was cause the Washington at home
and I'm just like,
oh my God.
You know,
cause she was landing those that hard
punches and it was,
I dunno.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
It was amazing.
Amazing.
A lot of people thought she had a chance
by submission because I'm a units is a
really good submission artist and she's
really fast.
Like she'll throw up flying armbars and
shit.
She's wild.
Crazy chances.
Yeah.
But for her to win by k like that,
it was like,
holy show it.
I know it.
I was so pumped when Daniel Cormier just
starts yelling out the thug.
Oh my God.
That was amazing.
Yeah.
It was one of my favorite moments of
doing commentary of be just being next
to him while he was yelling that out.
Cause it was just pure excitement and
appreciation and joy,
you know,
he's just having a good time.
Does he know her then too or do they,
I mean they all know each other.
Oh,
how well not training together?
No,
I don't believe so.
Not the same camp.
I mean maybe she's done some training at
Aka.
I don't,
I'm not aware of,
but she's,
she's in Colorado.
She's as Trevor Whitman and uh,
her,
uh,
boyfriend,
Pat Barry,
who's a worldclass kickboxer,
he's a really good a MMA fighter as
well.
When he remember him fight in the UFC,
he had some wild ass fight.
He's a serious striker.
Pat Barry can fucking crack.
I,
I remember,
I mean,
I thought he was fighting.
Let's see who was that?
And it's like,
I thought he was knocked out basically
and then landed one big one or maybe
it's the other way around.
Yeah,
he was fine.
Check Congo Congo completely out of it.
Yes.
And he just went in for broke and check
Congo caught him with a crazy kod.
Yeah,
that was it.
I remember that fight.
That was nuts.
It was nuts.
But that's just how pat fights.
He's a wild man.
He just fights wild.
Yeah,
he's,
he was,
I remember he was like thick and could
punch.
Yeah,
he's a tank.
Yeah.
It's ruthless leg kicks.
He got some of the best leg kicks I've
ever seen.
The heavyweight division.
Those are,
those are those lake you into that I
just heard you talk about the other day.
But those low leg kicks her new thing
nowadays.
Yeah.
Well Benson Henderson started doing that
a long time ago.
He was one of the first guys to
introduce it to mma.
But um,
he had some success with it.
But not like you've seen today.
Like you're seeing guys getting
debilitated like really quickly.
It must be a new,
so it's a weak spot for on humans,
I guess.
Well,
a hard discipline.
Their loans that Moitai fighters known
about forever,
that MMA fighters are just starting to
figure out the same as with kickboxing
and karate.
There's a lot of karate moves that MMA
fighters don't,
are not good at,
but karate guys are and karate guys come
into mma like Steven Tompkins,
uhs,
Thompson Thompson's,
wonderboy,
Tompkin,
Tom,
she keeps saying Tompkins cause of Sean
Tompkins.
Uh,
but a wonderboy is doing things from a
sideways karate stance that a lot of
people aren't just don't know how to
handle.
Like wonderboy has these crazy front leg
side kicks in front leg roundhouse
kicks.
Like if you ever watched his fight with
a Johnny Hendricks is one of the best
examples.
He hits Johnny Hendricks,
the gut with a sidekick.
And then Johnny Hendricks cause is still
there.
So he roundhouse kicks him in the face
with the same leg and you see Johnny,
he's like,
what in the fuck?
Cause it's just something like,
it's amazing to see that and training.
You don't know a lot of guys that you
have to get a really good karate guy and
most really good karate guys.
He's just gonna be able to take them
down.
Yeah.
But you know,
wonderboy is just got that style just
dialed in and nailed and he moves like a
snake from the waist.
Like he moves backwards from the weight,
like he gets away from Shit and then
fires back at Ya.
He looked good and that last fight,
yeah,
it gets jorge him on speed dial.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So that's a different style.
And so these,
these techniques,
like he's exceptionally good at those
karate techniques and a lot of people
aren't.
And so with Moitai most of the time when
guys were learning more time,
bringing it into mma,
they were doing a few things.
They were throwing the leg kicks,
they were throwing the knees to the
body,
the elbows,
normal,
normal Moitai techniques.
But they're missing some of the
subtleties.
So some of the better Moyie Thai
fighters started training with some of
the better MMA fighters.
And then slowly but surely those
techniques started leaking in.
I see.
And then the big one now is that low
like Kik,
that low leg kicks motherfucker,
man,
it just takes out your,
you can't condition your lower leg.
That's what I'm saying.
It's in,
it feels like it's a weeks.
I mean,
cause I know,
uh,
Michael Chandler,
he got
caught with that and that's how we lost
the belt and kill the nerves in his
legs.
And it's like,
it looked like his leg was broke,
his ankle is flopping all around.
You could,
you would swear that that leg was broke
and it must've just been those low leg
kicks down there and just deaden the
nerve.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
How many,
um,
how many fighter like,
Gilbert Melendez,
uh,
when he fought Jeremy Stevens,
Jeremy Stephens cracked him real early
in the first round without low leg kick
and you see it immediately swelling up
and then Gilbert has fallen down on it.
He keeps,
can't stand up on it.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Douglas Lema and Rory Macdonald,
Rory Macdonald in Beltour right into the
same thing right into the lower leg.
It's,
he had a giant Hematoma.
He was fucking huge.
Yeah.
It's a devastating technique.
Well,
it's interesting.
It's,
I just love that.
I love when new elements get brought
into this very complex sport.
Yeah.
I mean,
and that's like,
yeah,
that,
that's just been an a new one for sure.
Um,
but this Saturday,
are you going to be at the keep
hammering run this Saturday just to keep
hammering run where?
Salt Lake.
I didn't know there was one.
No,
no.
I'm going to be here now.
Remember that?
Uh,
you went to that show?
Yeah,
I did go to that show.
I just went to that show by accident.
The western hunting close doesn't town
skiing,
which I fucking hate.
Yeah.
I don't hate skiing,
but I'm not a fan.
This is boring.
You just dislike it a lot.
I just don't get it.
Every time I do it,
I'm like,
maybe this time I'm going to get it.
There's going to be the day where I'm an
employee.
I'm going to be in bliss.
I'm going to slide down that mountain.
People who goose cause you knew a good,
I did it for five years.
I got pretty good at it.
I didn't get good at it.
Like I couldn't enter a skiing
competition,
but I don't fall down anymore.
I know how to stop.
I know how to ski.
I just don't get it.
So I was there and then I was like,
what?
There's a hunting expo and I fucking
snuck away for a day.
I had a great time with you.
It was like,
this is so much better.
Yeah.
So that's this weekend that show.
Oh,
and you have a keep hammering run in
Utah.
Where's it at?
It's a,
if it's the same place as last year,
it's this,
right?
I mean,
we started the capital there in Salt
Lake Capitol building,
and then you run a five k from there.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So it's a Saturday morning.
I'm a big fan of salt lake.
I love that town too.
It's fucking great.
Yeah.
I mean it takes people,
man.
All I know there are so nice.
The best.
I mean,
I know,
it's weird.
There's a lot of Mormons there.
I know people get weirded out by more
ways.
Did the nicest people.
They're so nice.
Like I don't care what wacky shit you
believe.
As long as you're nice.
That's it.
Yeah.
Just be nice.
That's it.
Yeah.
So that's uh,
I'm excited it's going to be,
uh,
I think we were hoping to have,
kind of want to think we had a few
hundred last year,
so yeah.
Nice.
As can be.
And then,
uh,
we'll do that Saturday and then we'll be
back in September.
Oh,
cunning.
Ooh.
Do you remember that?
Remember El Canyon in Utah?
We only got to 470,000 views.
We're going to do a podcast when we get
to 500,000.
What's it out right now?
Jamie?
Go to the UAE hunt youtube page.
We might have to cancel this son of a
bitch.
Yeah.
We're hoping to do a podcast when it hit
500,000,
but it petered out.
It did petered out at about four,
four 71 to 70.
So we got a thousand today,
so we just need a few more days.
Good.
But end of the month.
Yeah,
we'll cut and close.
We'll hit it by the end of the month.
Hey.
And then,
then also,
uh,
this weekend,
um,
the secretary of the Interior Zinky on
Friday is going to announce a,
a a big,
I think it's a big win for
conservationists and,
um,
again,
we're going to protect the winter
migration routes for deer and elk from
development.
So that's been a big thing that,
you know,
like,
um,
I told,
I told them when I met with them back in
Vegas,
I don't know when it was a couple of
weeks ago that it feels like we've taken
some hits as sportsman,
as far as,
um,
the national monuments being shrunk,
you know,
and you can argue that both ways,
uh,
drilling on the,
on the coast,
you know,
a lot of people don't like the prospects
of that.
So I'm like,
man,
we could use it when and brought up the
winter migration routes and uh,
protecting those from,
from any development just so those
animals can get down and get to the
winter range.
Um,
when food is hard to come by.
And so that's,
that's going to be announced on Friday
that he's going to make that happen.
That's awesome.
And now you have a position there as
well.
Like what,
what is your official position?
That's it.
I'm on the International Wildlife
Conservation Council,
which has,
doesn't have anything to do with North
America,
but I'm just kind of using that as an
excuse to talk about North America.
It doesn't have anything to do with
North America.
Now what does it have to do with,
uh,
with that,
that's about like the trophy export ban
from Africa.
Oh,
so international hunting basically.
And so it,
it's a weighing in on that because it's
like if you go to Australia and you
shoot some animals,
you can't bring the meat back.
Um,
well,
yeah,
but that's different.
Yeah.
It's different.
Well,
that,
that doesn't have anything to do with
what's going on right now.
It's Africa and like with elephants
coming back,
so when you can't bring your trophy
back,
yeah.
Who's going to want to go shoot and not
just elephants because elephants are a
whole different category,
but who's going to go want to shoot a
gazelle?
Well,
if you,
if you can't bring it back.
Yeah.
Right.
I don't know if those are regulated,
but it's mostly elephants and you know,
in lions and lions they reversed it.
And then trump said,
fuck that trump doesn't like it.
Which is fascinating
because his sons,
yeah,
big hunters.
Right,
right.
He called it a horror show.
He did.
And that's what got my attention.
It's because he said that he doesn't see
how conservation helps elephants,
which,
okay,
that's one thing.
But then he said,
or any other animals and I'm like,
wait a second.
Okay.
You can't,
we can't say conservation hunting as a
conservation tool doesn't help any other
animals because we've proven here in
North America.
It's that it's a model that works.
So I didn't like how he worded that and
lump that all on together.
Now Mike was that,
I was,
was that just a poorly worded tweet?
What's going on here?
So then he said he's going to look at
that ban,
um,
regarding elephants because,
you know,
if there's no value on the animals,
we know it,
we know what happens.
Um,
and if there is no hunting,
it's pretty much the death sentence of
the animal.
Well,
we'd probably have to explain that to a
lot of people that don't know what we're
talking about.
But Africa,
there's a lot of animals in Africa that
were on the verge of extinction just a
few decades ago.
And what they did was,
it's a very controversial thing to,
especially to people that don't hunt.
But what they did was they created a lot
of these game preserves where they had
these animals and they had a financial
interest in keeping these animals alive
cause people paid a lot of money to come
over there and hunt them.
So now these animals that were on the
verge of extinction just a couple of
decades ago are thriving in record
numbers,
but they get hunted.
Yeah.
So for people that are concerned about
the welfare of these animals and they're
they,
they're wa wildlife lovers,
they're in a weird predicament because
it's hunting that's keeping these
animals alive.
And it seems like a contradiction.
Like how could hunting be conservation,
right?
But even in this country,
11% taxes on,
on bullets,
on hunting equipment,
on all the different things that people
buy.
And this was a self imposed tax that
sportsmen put on the purchase of these
goods so that it would go towards
wildlife and billions of dollars,
billions of dollars have gone to
preserving wetlands,
preserving wildlife habitat,
reestablishing populations of animals
and all these different areas where
they're diminished.
The amount of money that has gone
towards conservation from hunters versus
from Peta or the humane society or any
other welfare group,
it's not even remotely comparable.
Hunters are making the difference there.
And we put our money where our mouth is,
you know,
we say we care about it,
we,
we pay for it.
We,
we put money there to help conservation
and pay for the biologists and pay for
the studies and pay for habitat
enhancement.
And so that essentially is the same
thing that needs to happen in Africa is,
but it's,
it's weird to say,
well how can the United States regulate
what happens in Africa because we can't
really,
but we can say we're not going to allow
the trophies you come home.
So that pretty much stops a hunting in
Africa.
So,
yeah,
we're not saying you can or can't hunt
can still go do it.
You just can't bring them home,
which essentially stops a hunting
without hunting.
Those animals don't have value.
No.
And no matter how you want to slice it
or phrase it or whatever you want,
if they don't have value,
they're not going to,
it's going to be the detriment of the
animal of the specie.
Um,
you know,
Kenya,
they stopped hunting in 1973 and 70% of
the animals are gone with no hunting.
Yeah.
It's very confusing.
It's as it seems contradictory.
It does.
And it's like,
uh,
you know,
I talked to with,
um,
you know,
Zinky about this also.
And so that's what this,
this council was about to try to make a
good decision on how best to regulate
the trophies coming home and,
and maybe we can help promote hunting
and,
and how to do a ride and,
and what it means,
um,
as a council.
So that's,
I'm involved in that.
Um,
I use that opportunity to talk to them
about other things too.
But,
uh,
so I dunno,
I dunno where it's all gonna Kinda lead.
It's,
it's a fascinating subject because
elephants are endangered in some parts
of Africa,
but Africa is an enormous place and in
other parts of Africa they have a
problem with elephants.
Yeah.
So going to those places and shooting
elephants to most people is a horrific
offense.
Yeah.
So,
but the problem is I don't,
I don't see the amount of money that
someone has to pay to go and shoot an
elephant.
It's a crazy amount of money.
75,000 that's a lot of fucking money.
How many people are spending $75,000 to
go look at them or help them?
They're not going to,
they're not going to know.
And so,
and when you say,
well that money could come from photo
safaris?
No.
And also with the one's going to pay 75
grand to take a picture and for a photo
safari,
where they have them set up is that they
go on the pretty much the same route.
So the habitat just gets hammered.
I mean,
you know what a national monument or a
national park here,
the most popular places,
you know what those look like?
Fricking dump.
So when you have those photos far as
they go on the same track,
basically you're hammering the habitat,
you're not getting back to the back
reaches where the poachers are killing
the animals,
you know,
that's still happening back there.
And then to get a pride of lion in tour,
you can take pictures of it.
They're still going out and shooting
zebras and,
and,
and Paula and in different things.
Buffalo throwing them out there.
So the,
so the lions are,
they're eating.
So there's still animals dying,
but they're just,
the animals aren't benefiting from it.
So when you think of like in the Bush of
Africa,
if uh,
a farmer there has a crop and there's
elephants getting in,
they're thrashing his crop,
the elephant has no value to them.
What has value as a crop?
And if the animal,
if the elephants in,
they're trampling it.
He just wants to elfant debt once
they've gone.
So he's going to shoot,
it's going to lay there.
It's,
you're not going to benefit anybody but
his crop grows and that's what happens.
It's just very hard for people to look
at it that way because they look at it
like,
no,
I don't want an elephant to die.
No,
I want a lion to die.
no,
no.
I don't want a zebra to die and I don't
want to draft a die and we can go ahead
and shoot that other thing.
That wart hog,
the ugly thing,
nobody gives a fuck about warhawks you
can shoot warhawks and smile and take a
picture and people are racist.
They were racist against certain
animals.
That's a fact.
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
The fact,
is it racism,
racism,
race of speciesism or you speciest I am.
I sent you a video about that.
Speciesist that's a fact.
But,
and people way more than I like
goldfish.
And,
and with regard to lions,
you know,
so if lions are coming in and killing
the goats or whatever that the say in
Tanzania that they're raising,
they're just going to put,
there'll be a dead goat.
They'll put poison in it.
The,
the pride will come in,
eat it,
they'll go die.
Then no more goats are getting killed.
All those lines are dead.
Well that was one of the things about
Zimbabwe,
right?
Um,
was it Zimbabwe where that guy killed
that lion?
The Cecil?
Oh,
I think so.
Yeah.
That place they had to kill a bunch of
lions because people stopped lion
hunting there.
And so because they stopped line hunting
there,
they had this excess of lions and they
were destroying the Angelo population.
So they had to go in and just slaughter
these lions.
Yeah.
So the $50,000 per line that they would
have made,
that would have gone towards all sorts
of different things,
protection of the habitat,
the,
the different conservation officers that
work in that area instead that there's
no money and then they actually have to
hire someone to go and do that job.
Right.
And this is the argument about British
Columbia as well.
This is exactly what's going to happen
up there.
That the argument that you're getting
from the people that are in the field
that are out there every day is that
what's going to have to happen is you're
going to have a bunch of problem bears.
They're going to have to hire people
that go out to these problem bears and
it's incredibly expensive and very,
very dangerous.
Yeah.
And bears are going to die.
So still still going to have of them.
Some of them are still going to die.
Yeah.
But animals are going to die.
You know what I mean?
Do you get mad when a bear kills an
antelope or when a bear kills a giraffe
or,
right.
Well,
they don't really,
they're not over there.
But if they were over here,
you know,
if a bear kills a Moose,
are you upset?
Are you only upset when a person killed
a moose?
Right.
And you know,
in Africa too,
and so those animals are dying.
Um,
and w when it's hunters that are doing
it,
the numbers are very controlled.
The harvest is very controlled.
You can take x amount of animals out and
this money will go towards,
you know,
this enhancement of a waterhole,
this pain for um,
the anti poaching unit,
which when I was over there was $1,000 a
day to pay for guys to come in to,
to control,
keep the poachers out of there without
that money.
Um,
none of that's happening.
So there instead of having a very
regulated harvest number,
the poachers will kill hell over mini.
Yeah.
And let's be honest about it,
the vast majority of the money is going
towards whatever lodge,
the owners of that for sure area.
But they're also hiring people.
They are hiring people,
but they have a financial incentive to
keep these animals alive.
It's very peaceful.
It's very problematic for a lot of
people.
They don't like to hear it.
And I've,
I've read this article that's ridiculous
article that said that that's not true,
that trophy hunting is not what sustains
these animals.
And you know,
you can get just as much from a safari.
Like that's not true.
What you're saying is not true.
That CNN thing handled it pretty well.
Did you watch that tracks?
What did you think about that?
Um,
no,
I,
I'm a hunter.
Said some stupid shit.
I didn't God,
you know,
I mean,
we talked about this earlier in the
podcast,
you know,
when people say,
Oh,
you just want to go kill stuff and this
and that.
I didn't really like when whoever the
hunter was,
I don't know.
It's probably a nice guy.
But he shot a crocodile and he says,
yeah,
mother effer.
And I'm like,
what is going on there?
I wouldn't know.
I've never done anything like that and
that,
that seemed,
that isn't like the honorable hunter
that I know,
you know?
So that seems a little weird.
I don't like crocodiles.
I might say.
Yeah,
mother fucker.
If I shot the crocodile crocodile,
scare the shit out of me.
I'm here.
The one thing that scares me more than
any,
pretty much any animal on the planet.
Yeah,
I know.
I just,
I,
I still feel a lot of respect for the
animal.
I'm joking around most of the,
I know,
but I did just seem like a weird
reaction to me.
Well,
especially knowing that the world is
going to see that reaction.
Yeah.
I mean,
if he was just by himself and he said
that,
and that was an honest reaction and
who's still had respect for the animal
and it was just the fact that he pulled
it off.
Yeah.
It's unfortunate.
It's unfortunate as,
uh,
it's unfortunate to broadcast that for
the world to see.
Yeah.
I thought,
I thought it could have been a lot worse
with regard to how hunters were
portrayed.
You know,
I mean,
um,
even the guy who killed the lion,
he did get emotional.
Um,
he showed some reverence there,
which,
which I liked.
Um,
it could have been worse.
Uh,
they talked about how it's animals are,
I guess a commodity in some respects
with the rhinos.
You know,
they,
I think that guy had 1500 rhinos,
didn't he,
on his property and uh,
you know,
so what's better,
1500 rhinos for him to have and raise
and cut off the horns or zero.
Yeah.
You know,
it's better to have 1500.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
it's definitely better for the
population of rhinos as a whole because
people don't like the idea of raising
something as a commodity,
raising wildlife as a commodity.
I understand that.
Do you ever see the Louis through
documentary about wildlife in Africa
about those,
I forget what it was called,
but you can watch it on youtube.
That to me was a,
a better piece.
And one of the most interesting things,
because Louie is a,
he's a very smart guy,
but he's also a very nice guy.
He just kept asking questions and
pestering people and getting to the
heart of it.
But he also showed like these fenced in
Lyons and they're throwing a dead cow
over the top of the fence.
And the lines have been tearing it
apart.
It's fucking crazy.
I didn't see it.
But it's,
it's weird because the,
these lions,
they're never like,
they're feeding
him and then people go over there and
hunt them as if it's like a wild lion.
Yeah,
it's,
it's super weird.
I couldn't hunt and offense.
Um,
I cannot align in a fence.
so I don't know.
Yeah.
It,
it's not what we call over here in
America.
Fair Chase,
right?
There's a,
a term,
that term fair chase is synonymous with
ethical hunters in America.
And this is something that most people
aren't aware of that there's a code and
that code the code very slightly.
Like in some places you can use
electronic communication,
meaning you can use walkie talkies to
locate an animal.
Like a,
I believe you can do that in Arizona.
You definitely could do that in Nevada.
You can't do that in Montana.
You know,
there's,
there's different things of what people
decide.
It's fair chase or ethical and it
depends.
Like Colorado,
they won't even let you use a,
a light on your site,
on your both site can have any
electronics,
uh,
attached to your site for whatever
reason.
They just started allowing lighted nocks
well that was just an Oregon too,
or they've been outlawed in Oregon I
think.
I mean,
I haven't used them in Oregon,
but,
uh,
I think they are legal now.
But yeah,
I mean as far as,
so you're trying to define what is fair
chase.
Right.
And so yeah,
there's a lot of these electronics,
this or that.
But what we say is fair chase is not in
a high fence.
Well it's definitely not feeding a lion
in a cage and then opening up the door.
Right when the hunter pulls up,
that is due to,
Oh yeah,
that is what they do.
It's one of the reasons why a lot of
these lines that get shot,
they don't know what the fuck is going
on.
They're bedded somewhere.
They just lay down cause they're outside
in this new environment.
Like where am I?
And even know what it is because they've
been living in this very small
environment and they let them out and
they let him out right when the hunter
gets,
yeah,
that's,
that's tougher to justify.
It's very tough to justify.
It's,
I,
I feel like it's,
it's,
it's not justifiable.
Yes.
You're not hunting anymore.
You're just murdering an animal.
Yeah.
So I'm murder.
Murder is a person right now,
so I'm going to,
I'm going to not address that part and
just address hunting in general and
hunting in general is what's necessary
for the,
the future of animals.
I mean,
you had until it gets down to a number
where maybe the white or black or
whatever rhino that is,
that's only down to a hound handful.
Obviously you're not going to hunt
those.
But by and large,
hunting is what keeps these animals,
the population viable.
Well,
and then there was also the case of
Corey Knowles who went over there and
Knowlton no,
Nolan.
Corey Knowlton Knowlton.
Yup.
Does that he say his name?
Sorry,
Corey.
Corey Knowlton.
We got it.
Why does he noise?
But yeah,
I have too many names in my head.
But anyway,
when cory went over there in
cornerstone,
the hotspot smoking.
You think so?
No,
but that's what people like to say,
right?
Yeah.
People would see a lot of stupid shit.
Seven pop quiz motherfucker.
Shit.
But when cory went
over there,
he spent a quarter of a million dollars
to shoot an endangered rhino,
think it was 350,000 was it that much?
I mean it was a lot,
a lot of money,
hundreds of thousands of dollars.
And he said that it was undervalued and
he said the reason why the bidding
didn't get higher it was because there
was so much pressure on people to do it.
But he explained very eloquently and
very clearly on CNN and when he did my
podcast about all the death threats that
he got,
what he said,
listen,
that rhino was killing other rhinos.
That is why not breeding,
not breeding.
It was,
it was an old rhino that was past its
breeding prime.
It wasn't breeding anymore and it was
killing the young rhinos.
He had killed a female that had tried to
mate with and it had killed another male
and it was,
they were,
these was,
this is an endangered animal and this
thing was killing other animals.
They had decided,
look,
we have to take this out of the
population,
so what is the best money for it to get
a tremendous amount of money that could
go for anti poaching efforts and all
these different things.
And so he explained it like,
he's like,
this is,
this is an animal that they were going
to kill.
They had to kill it because it was
threatening this endangered population
of only like a couple of thousand
rhinos.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
It's a really interesting situation.
And people would like it if that wasn't
the case,
they would like it if no,
the money is actually coming from animal
welfare groups and from wildlife lovers
who just want to see these animals
alive.
The difference is it's very rare that
someone is going to give you $350,000 to
keep a rhino a lot.
Huh.
And so that,
that's a magnified example,
but that's pretty much what's happening
with all the animals.
I mean,
you're not getting that much money,
but you're getting money in exchange for
their life,
basically.
And it's for the betterment of the herd.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's hunting.
Yeah.
Right?
I mean,
that's,
that's like,
like I said,
very magnified because you're getting a
huge amount of money and there's only a
few animals,
but you can,
it's easy to see,
hey,
killing this one is going to save
animals.
So that's really easy to see.
But that's pretty much what happens with
all animals.
I mean,
you're balancing that heard.
The other thing is they ate that rhino
and a lot of people at that Rhino,
I mean,
they give you a need a way to villages
and people don't know you.
You not only can you eat rhinos,
apparently they taste good.
Same thing with elephant.
Elephant apparently tastes delicious.
Well,
do you remember in the trophy movie
they,
they could care less what elephant that
guy killed,
but they didn't like that it was small.
Right?
Do you remember that in me?
Because they wanted more meat.
They don't care about,
they want it.
They care about eating.
Yeah,
that's it.
So as far as the locals go,
I mean,
so we here in America,
it feels like,
you know,
we take up these causes and it's like,
we're the social justice warriors for
the world.
It's like we ought to probably check in
with the people that actually live
there,
right?
Yeah.
They want to kill the lions.
Jesus Christ.
He sees a kid.
There was a,
an article in the New York Times shortly
after the,
the Lion Cecil the lion controversy.
It said a in Zimbabwe.
We did not cry for lions.
Right.
I know that.
Read that one.
Yeah.
No,
that's,
and that's,
that's real life.
I mean,
over here,
everything,
Lion,
king,
everything lives everybody's friends.
But Simba is my friend.
Yeah.
No one's saying that.
Lions need to die.
No,
I look,
I'm not in favor of those high fence
things and the way they keep those
lines.
A lot of things you've told me before,
you wouldn't have on,
no,
I'm right.
No desire.
Right.
So,
but you understand teen and how it works
and,
and how,
what we need.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just a weird facet of human nature
that we've sort of boxed ourselves into
this situation with Africa.
But Africa I think is,
you could look to that example and,
and see how it's is a very complex
issue.
Especially,
let's take all the woods.
Steve Rinella calls the charismatic
megafauna out of the equation like
giraffes,
which everybody loves.
Like I had a whole bit about giraffes
and one of my comedy specials that
they're,
the one animal that you can't say is
like,
is not better off in the zoo.
Yeah.
Because like other animals,
they look like captive.
They're contained.
But giraffes are so happy babies
freedom.
Like I used to take my kids to the zoo
when my daughter was,
I don't even think she was two.
She's holding out of a piece of lettuce
and a fucking giraffe comes out to hedge
huge giant Tang wraps around the lettuce
and takes it from,
and she's giggling and laughing,
but they're so confident in giraffe
behavior that they let babies feed them.
Yeah.
That's impressive.
Or animal like that.
And the zoo.
No,
because animals are wild animals,
you know,
done all that they're going to do.
But what I said was that a giraffe wakes
up every day in the zoo and goes another
day with no lions.
That's true.
And just sort of wanders around the zoo
having a,
they look like they're having a blast,
but they have not a care in the world.
They don't mind at all being in that
fence long as you keep chucking that,
hey,
over the side there are good.
Keep it coming.
Keep dead.
Hey,
come on baby.
Yeah,
good to go.
We have connections with certain
animals.
Elephants are a big one,
you know?
Um,
lions are a big one.
Giraffes for whatever reason are a big
one.
Even zebras,
people like,
why are you shooting at a zebra?
It's too much like a horse.
Yeah.
Like we have these,
but if it's like an antelope like that,
you eat like,
oh,
that kinda makes sense.
Yeah.
Like we have these kind of makes sense
animals.
And again,
wart hogs.
Nobody gives a fuck about warthogs.
There's no one out there trying to save
the Warhawk.
People don't even know how many there
are.
They don't care and care less.
No.
This is not like people worried about
lions and no one is out there wondering
how many ward hogs are all left in
Africa.
I see it all the time.
It's like people will comment,
not hunters,
IVC,
but they'll be like on my page and say,
well,
oh,
I don't have a problem if you kill deer
and elk,
but there's no reason to kill a bear.
Right.
What are you talking about?
Have you ever had bear sausage?
Yeah.
Well,
if you've had bear saw and you,
you probably happen.
But if you,
if,
if you have,
it's Goddamn good.
And why is it any different?
It's the same.
Why is it any different?
Yeah,
it's not.
so it's just what they're,
it's just what they're ingrained to feel
about an animal,
I think.
Well,
they,
they seem to dog like,
so yeah,
that's a thing.
That's the thing with people that bears
or seem dog like,
oh well they're portrayed as being nice
and the people have them for pets too.
Like there's a lot of people that have
bears pets,
like a of Russian design up people and
man on instagram.
Do you have lunch?
Fine.
Them.
This is one motherfucker as a giant
grizzly bear that he cuddles with and
people keep sending me videos of this
guy.
I'm like,
one day,
I know I say this video is going to get
dark.
God.
Yeah,
look at this guy.
It's got a sweet bear.
Just chilling with this bird,
this bird month moon.
When we hung out,
my girlfriend,
no rubbers back,
but one day my baby.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It looks like it looks like a cool bear.
It's dope bear.
Look,
they're fucking awesome animals man.
I love all of them.
Yeah.
But here's the deal.
If you had a thousand of those living in
your neighborhood,
you'd have to thin the herd.
Yeah.
You just have to,
and the reality of all this stuff is
super complex and I just do not think
you get an understanding of it from,
you know,
in front of your laptop in Vancouver.
You just,
you don't know for sure.
What I like is,
uh,
you know,
with regard to like this international
wildlife council or even,
um,
it just seems like with this
administration and people say good or
bad or mostly bad,
it feels like you're listening to about,
and that's what,
that's one thing that I would read cnn
and I listened to fight.
It's like the same topic,
two totally different slants.
So it's like what the hell?
Who Do you believe?
So that's why I was happy to be involved
so I can actually hear.
But still it's still hard.
It's still hard to listen and think,
okay,
so what's going on?
But,
but with my whole thing is like,
I kind of look at it is if I got
somebody online giving me advice or you
give me advice,
I'd be like,
well Joe knows me.
I'm going to listen to him.
That's why I kind of want her to be
involved in these councils and in this
part of this decision making because
they can listen to all of this people
talking shit all day.
But if I'm there and can actually weigh
in,
we'll then they know me.
And,
and you know,
it might,
it should weigh a little more and they
know your experience.
Right?
And so that's why I want to be involved.
I'm not saying I'm going to agree and
it's going to be exactly what I wanted
every time.
But,
you know,
I don't know how else
to do it.
I don't know how else to do it.
And I know that with my voice because,
you know,
they have trusted me about whatever.
Even if they agree or don't agree,
I'll at least get to share my thoughts.
And so that's what I did.
You know,
like when I talked with Zinky the other
day,
what does he like?
That's what he's an avid hunter,
right?
Yeah.
That's what,
you know,
and I've read all these man,
you'd think he was the word just like
trump,
you know,
people,
you'd think they were saddened to some
people.
But to me,
um,
I read the outside magazine article on
them.
It sounded terrible and I was like,
God,
that's not good.
I read a few other things about them.
I'm like,
but to me personally is seamed,
would listen.
Um,
seemed like somebody who,
if we were sitting there talking about
something and we came to a decision and
it made sense,
that's what it seemed like,
like a normal,
you know,
a well thought out person.
Well I think he's probably got a
tremendous amount of pressure on him
from a bunch of different angles for
sure.
All interested in making money for sure.
And they think of someone that is pro
wildlife as being a roadblock to the
money.
Yeah.
Like,
Oh,
this fucking green house loving hippy
tree hugging asshole.
He,
what he told me is he's concerned he
wants to increase hunting opportunities
and you know,
um,
public land opportunities,
you know,
so that's,
and that's kind of what I want to hear.
So I mean,
maybe what would of who you're talking
to.
I understand that,
but it sounds as sounds good.
I mean,
it gave me a better feeling talking to
them then reading the other articles and
the articles about him.
Right.
So,
uh,
and then the,
his staff,
great people,
like I said,
just like we'd sit here and talk and it
makes sense.
And even talking with Donald Trump jr
I'd be like,
God,
I wish we could just do this right now.
Because it's like you can actually come
to a consensus,
make a decision,
talk it through and be like,
that's how it should be,
you know?
And it seems,
it feels like it's different.
Politics are different because
everybody,
like you said,
there's pressure from different places.
But when I think of a politician,
I think,
you know,
special interest groups and these other
people that,
that are influenced him and you're
wondering why is this for their own
benefit?
And so you don't really know with this,
it doesn't feel like that.
It feels like it's trying to make the
right decision,
you know,
without being influenced.
I know there's always gonna be
influenced,
but without like the special interest
type influence,
I don't know.
You know,
I think the more people like you that
are involved in this and the more people
like you have a say,
or at least,
or they'd come to you for advice,
you're going to get it at least a more
balanced perspective of what the
potential hazards are and what's
important.
What we need to concentrate on.
You know,
I think regardless
of what you sing about trump,
what people were excited about about him
as a president would be that the economy
would have an upswing and it did.
But lately the last couple of days has
been a massive decline in the stock
market.
Has been yesterday I think was the
biggest loss ever.
I don't understand the stock market.
I really don't get it at a bunch of
assholes throwing their hands in the
air.
There's computers that are doing a lot
of the calculation that's going on.
It's too fucking confusing.
I feel like if I just went down that
rabbit hole,
I'd be stuck studying the stock market
for weeks upon weeks and I just don't
have that kind of time.
Dude,
I gotta play techno hunt with Cam hands.
Well and I like,
I like reading stuff.
Like,
you know,
the stock market's at an all time high
and he's making money.
That's all I heard.
I heard that.
Nothing but that.
Like jobs,
like more jobs than ever,
you know?
Unemployments and all time low.
I'm like,
well,
you know,
when you have a guy who was just so hell
bent on making money in business,
it's good for business.
Right.
So like that would be the benefit of
having a guy like that.
But then apparently there's some
downsides to that shit and the downsides
are inflation and a panic.
And then once the stock market starts
going south and people start freaking
out,
then it really goes south and now it's
really gone south.
Well last couple of days.
I mean it's like I live in the moment
and campaigns.
I'm not here for your fucking rosy view
of the future.
Sorry,
I don't even understand the stock
market.
I don't understand it.
Yeah.
I like,
I like hearing good news.
That's what I like hearing.
Yeah.
I like,
I like I get comforted here and people
that,
that uh,
I'm not wondering about what their
intentions are.
So,
um,
that's why I enjoyed the discussions
with those guys.
And Yeah.
You know,
if I can,
if you know,
I just said,
you know,
it feels like as sportsman we took a
couple of hits,
we could use something on the positive
side and I think we're getting that on
Friday.
So that's so on Friday are they gonna
make new rules in terms of what you can
bring back and what you can't bring back
the idea behind it?
No,
that's not about the international.
This is about the,
the core doors.
Yeah.
Right.
So protection per protecting migration
routes for the big game animals here.
That's very,
it's very important.
Yeah.
Especially for animals like mule deer
whose populations aren't really that
good.
But now,
yeah,
the elk elk still need to be able to get
out of the high country out from,
you know,
where they breed down when the weather,
when the weather hits to get down to
where the feed is and if there's a bunch
of gas rigs in there,
knock me able to do it.
Do you follow Gritty Bowman on
instagram?
You Do,
right?
Yeah.
Brian was taking all these videos of elk
in evergreen.
Hell,
I know.
Wander right through town.
And they're huge.
These people are just hanging out near
cars.
I know they have zero fear of people I
know.
And they know that once they're in the
town that's like they're on home base
there.
They're safe.
It's weird how they know that,
you know.
Oh,
I know.
I did.
I did see that there are some nice
animals in their crazy beautiful people
pulled over just checking them out and
they're screaming and running.
We're that they just migrate right
through the town.
Yeah.
So they probably figured out a long time
ago,
Hey,
just keep waving the car isn't nobody
fucks with you.
We're good to go.
But you know,
they have weird rules in evergreen where
you could kind of hunting your backyard.
Oh really?
I didn't know that.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If you want a certain amount of
property,
I think it's like more than an acre.
He could fucking check,
boom.
Watch right in your backyard.
You had a full freezer then.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think that's exactly why they made
those rules.
Um,
I think it's by section,
you know,
by unit,
depending upon where you're at.
Right.
But in some places you,
you literally can hunt in your backyard.
So I would imagine the elk avoid those
places.
I would think so.
They live pretty quick.
Isn't it interesting they learn quick?
Well that's the one of the things that
they said about reintroduction of wolves
into yellowstone,
they figured it out after awhile.
They look okay.
Like for in the beginning they were just
sitting ducks.
Yeah.
You know,
but that was in the 90s and now we're in
2018 it's essentially the ecosystem has
sorted itself out and there's some good
arguments that it's sorted itself out
for the better.
Yeah.
You know,
which is,
you know,
for the betterment of other wildlife,
other plant species of the elk word,
you know,
eating a shit load of them.
So it's,
it's interesting,
but also you should know that where they
brought those wolves back,
you can't hunt.
Right.
Cause this,
the greater yellowstone eco systems,
like it's all protected.
Right.
So maybe they needed him there.
Yeah.
It's hard to say.
Just don't bring them Colorado fuckers.
Don't do it.
There you go.
Tell him to it.
So what else are you going to discuss
with Zinky?
How often do you meet?
Like what does this job entail or this
position entails on that?
Council says there's,
you meet twice a year.
So I didn't really know what about or
when that's going to happen.
But,
uh,
for me and my,
my whole thing is like,
well,
if I want to get to know somebody,
I like to have them do what I do.
It's like you.
And so he says he has a bow and I'm
like,
you.
I said,
what kind of bow?
He told me kind of battle.
I'm like,
what kind of,
uh,
I said,
what did he have?
Like a horse got one.
Now it's an old ball.
Oh really?
God,
I can eat like a high country,
something like that,
that,
something like that.
But I'm like [inaudible].
So anyway,
I said,
well,
you want to shoot that Bo?
He's like,
yeah.
I said,
well,
I'll hook them up with hoyt.
I'll,
they can't take any gifts.
Oh,
I can't take gifts.
So I said,
I said,
cause I said that and I,
and uh,
I said,
well,
don't worry about that.
I go to shoot your bow.
I said,
how about if I come back in a two d c
there and we,
and we shoot bows and can't give,
you can't give him a gift as a friend.
I don't know that it's maybe from a
would be an issue.
It's pretty regulated.
Oh,
that makes sense.
Taking whatever you can only take bribes
under the table.
Take gifts,
can't have that actual bow.
Isn't that funny?
You could take campaign contributions.
Yeah.
But not about,
you can't take a boat.
You could have lobbyists that are on
staff that are trying to get cached and
working those special interest groups.
Come on baby.
Well,
so next is a bow we talked about next
week,
me gone back there and shooting bows
with him.
Yep.
And talking just about whatever,
you know,
just kind of helmet,
want to see his form.
That has,
right.
So,
uh,
we're trying to make that happen.
And,
uh,
I just,
you know,
like I said,
if you have somebody's ear,
you just want to be able to tell them
what's important to you and that's all I
want to do.
But I can do that generally better over
something I care about,
like archery or running or lifting
weights or whatever like that.
So that's my goal just to,
you know,
share what's what,
because I feel like I have a pretty good
pulse on what's important to sportsmen
and hunters here in North America.
And,
uh,
so I just want to share that.
Well,
I know Donald Trump junior is an avid
archer.
Like he's really into it.
He's an avid hunter plate.
Yeah.
And He,
you got a chance to talk to him?
Yeah.
Uh,
quite a quite a while.
Yeah.
He wants to do the podcast,
this podcast.
Yeah.
So he,
he,
you know,
me,
you and him can talk,
uh,
talk about hunting.
Okay.
We're in dawn,
so they smoke weed first,
for sure.
Oh,
No total normal.
I mean,
cause that possible.
How's it possible that you grow up with
Donald Trump as your dad?
You've got a golden toilet bowl.
When that little kid,
that's what I said,
I said,
you know,
I go,
cause I,
I haven't met any of of uh,
Donald's kids except for Don Jr.
So I'm like,
well,
but I follow them on Instagram,
you know,
you kind of get it.
I do to kind of a sort of a feel for
what the,
I said,
man,
I go,
you know,
in talking to you,
I said it,
it seems weird to say,
but seem like a normal gun,
which is your dad's a billionaire.
I don't know.
Is he a billionaire?
Right.
Oh yeah.
So doesn't that seem,
it seems surprising.
He's like,
seems like just like we would be right.
Total normal.
I mean he's,
I fall on my instagram.
I see that the pictures of his daughter,
super cute,
the fishing pictures,
but I saw him on Tucker Carlson the
other night and I told them this and we
were talking in Vegas and he was like,
just laying it down for a one minute
clip on instagram on Tucker Carlson was
to Fox News and laying it down.
And I was like,
God,
I never really had followed his
political or is his public speaking type
life.
So I was like,
holy crap,
this guy is pretty dialed in.
It's probably the plan it takes over
when he might retire,
you might,
I mean,
he's 40 so he's just kind of getting his
feet
under slides right in and that world and
trump dynasty just like they did with
the bushes.
That's right.
Just know all of up Clinton's clenches.
You know,
once you're in there,
it's like that's all they want is not
interesting.
It's crazy.
But he,
I would feel,
I mean man,
well that's what said electrical guy.
I wish the don junior was running for
president.
Yeah,
he's don junior is very reasonable.
Oh Man.
Totally.
Totally funny if he,
if he says one thing wrong,
one thing,
one slip up of a word,
which by the way,
everybody does every day.
I do it every day.
Yeah,
me too.
One one slip up of the word Corey
Knowlton right.
One fuck up like that.
And then this done,
I mean,
you see all this,
this magnified,
ridiculous hate that comes his way.
And the attacks against him.
And people are people right now
listening to this,
probably yelling at them because they're
fucking Joe's to Ford.
Here's a show.
It's yet.
Yeah,
they,
it's,
I mean it is really hard not to get
pissed off.
What's really hard to be unbiased?
It's really hard to just have enough
amounts perspective.
And I don't think anybody does a good
job as president.
I've never seen a single person do it
well.
I've seen Obama give very good speeches.
I think he's very statesman.
Like I think he's,
he's very,
what Obama did that was a excellent was
he was very composed and articulate and
smooth and he represented a highly
educated,
like a high level of human being in
terms of his intellect and the way he
carries himself.
And I think that that's good for the
country,
you know?
But I think the way you look at the
drone attacks,
you look at the attacks on,
on whistle blowers and on the press,
and there was a lot of bad shit about
the Obama administration and everybody
wants to sleep sweep under the rug
because I think nobody's a good
president.
I think it's a terrible job at it.
I didn't like how he,
he sort of started a war on cops.
You remember when he was,
you know,
cruise fine,
some of the arrest they had and it
started,
people were looking at cops thinking,
these are the good guys are the bad
guys.
I didn't like that because maybe there
are some bad cops,
but there's bad.
Everything you do,
every job has bad,
whatever.
So hundred percent.
Instead of highlighting that people out
there protecting our interests in,
in serving the public,
he was highlighting the quote,
bad cops I guess,
and it put them all in a bad light.
I didn't like that.
Whereas trump,
he knows,
you know,
he's highlighting good police work.
He's highlighting the military.
He's,
you know,
pride in,
in Ah,
the good old United States of America.
I like that.
So I mean,
I dunno.
Yeah.
Well,
the thing that drove me nuts,
the most nuts about Obama was that crazy
speech that he said,
if you have a business that doesn't
choose the highway,
you didn't build up.
Yeah.
You didn't build that,
build that business.
You don't build that like that.
That is,
that is the craziest way to look at
things.
Yeah.
If I was his friend,
I would say,
okay,
this is not the way to say what he did.
I think he started like highlight the
victim mentality.
Everybody's a victim.
Whereas I like trump.
He says,
you're in control.
Here's your opportunity.
Make the most of it.
I would see it very differently.
I would have said,
if you have a business and you start at
yourself,
congratulations.
This is what American ingenuity is all
about,
but we all have to be aware,
not just you not singing that person so
you didn't build up.
Yeah.
I would say we all have to be aware of
that.
Without our infrastructure,
we would,
none of us would be able to do that.
So we all have to support this beautiful
system that we have in an empowering way
instead of,
you didn't do it,
you didn't build it.
Yeah.
Taking credit away from people who
worked their ass off.
And by the way,
he's a guy who's never been in business,
right?
Just,
he's a lawyer.
He went from being a lawyer to being a
professional politician to being the
president.
Yeah.
Bam,
Bam.
I mean,
this is,
that's one thing I don't like is people
who are like,
their goal is to be a politician.
Well,
I don't like that.
I'd like it if they were awesome at it,
but no one that I like.
It seems like the best.
Like even back in,
you know,
that,
when our country was founded,
it,
those weren't politicians.
Those were guys who had influenced,
who made good decisions and then they
were politicians.
You know what I mean?
I've been watching vikings a lot lately.
It's new.
Show up and watch him gay.
And,
uh,
it seems like there's no good leaders in
the Viking world.
There was bad leaders.
This leader suck.
Nobody wants,
nobody wants a Goddamn leader.
And when you're a leader of 350 million
people or whatever the hell we have
here,
it's just impossible.
It doesn't make any sense what's going
on,
Jamie?
I just looked up that quote out of
context,
but he said it.
He said those two sentences,
but not in that way.
Oh,
if you've got a business they,
and build up a fake news.
Okay.
So what is the actual quote?
Wait,
what's her?
The real quote.
If you were successful,
somebody lung,
lung,
Davies,
some help,
there was a great teacher,
okay?
But what does it,
if you've got a business,
you didn't build that.
Okay?
Somebody invested in roads and bridges.
Okay,
here it is.
Somebody helped create this unbelievable
American system that we have allowed you
to throw that have,
uh,
that we have that allowed you to thrive.
Somebody invested in the roads and
bridges.
If you've got a business,
you didn't build that.
That's just a shitty way to say it.
I don't care.
Even in context.
Somebody else made that happen.
Yeah.
Not,
not somebody else.
We all chipped in.
Did I know that's what he's saying.
But it's a shit way to say it.
It's a shit disempowering way to say it
is.
That's what I don't like.
Takes credit away from the people that
there's a way to do that.
There's a way to phrase that that needs
an edit and rewrite.
And by the way,
how the fuck could even have time to do
that when you're writing.
I mean,
you're writing under the pressure of
being the president of the United
States.
I totally sympathize.
I get it.
I'm not saying I would have done better.
I would have done way worse,
but it still sucks.
Yeah.
It's just not a good way to say things.
You're going to do that.
I don't,
you said you said disempowering and
that's exactly right.
And so,
um,
it feels like this is,
there's a different tone right now.
And I'm not saying,
you know,
our president is perfect.
Just say white people.
You like my people.
I'm not saying that at all.
I'm not saying that at all,
but I'm just saying nobody's perfect.
But I liked that part of the message.
Well,
he definitely has that part of the
message,
but he's obviously said a bunch of
stupid shit too,
but he's also a guy flies off the cuff.
I mean this,
we have to take into consideration what
this guy was his entire career.
He's a giant larger than life
personality with crazy hair,
who puts his name on everything and then
he ran for president.
Of course he's going to stay that guy
when he becomes president.
We go down to know now that you're
president,
it's like when you,
when you're in,
if you're playing beauty and the beast
and you're the beast,
you've got to act like the beast.
Now you've got the role and actually at
the like,
why are you still acting like hugh
grant?
Yeah.
You know you can't,
I know it's the role of being the
president is this,
you know,
this majestic top of the mountain that
we look at like,
oh,
he's the guy.
He's the main dude where you're supposed
to act like the president.
Like,
yeah,
that's what they say.
He's not presidential.
He never has been.
But you know what?
He's been a leader,
you know,
so here's what I know.
I don't see anybody,
I don't see isis over here bombing the
shit out of the United States anymore
cause they're almost,
they're all dead.
There's a lot.
Well,
there's a lot,
but they were never bombing the shit out
of the United States and trying to a few
dummies that snuck over here and did
some stupid shit here.
Horrible Shit.
Yeah.
Look,
the one thing that the military has said
and friends of mine that are in the
military and guys like Tim Kennedy that
rejoined.
Yeah,
he said that they feel like for the
first time in a long time,
the military is basically got the
handcuffs off and that they are allowed
to do things the way they think would be
best.
Right.
And a lot of people don't like to hear
that.
They like to say,
well no,
the politicians are supposed to control
the military and it's supposed to be,
you're not supposed to allow the
generals to make the decisions.
There's a,
there's a debate back we need,
and this is again like a lot of other
things because a very complex,
nuanced conversation that you'd have to
have all the facts at your disposal.
I don't know either do it,
but I can say they're not bombing the
shit of the United States and sound like
a complete redneck.
Right.
And that's how I see it.
But I understand there is,
I mean you need a stride a military
because the world has some dark places
and anybody who doesn't think that you
need a strong military,
you need to pay attention to what the
fuck is going on in Syria,
in North Korea,
and a lot of parts of the world where
they there chaos and this is a,
an entirely real possibility anywhere,
anywhere that exists,
it can exist here.
If you see horrible tyranny and
destruction and chaos and other parts of
the world,
the only reason why it's not here is
because of geography.
If they can get there,
they can get here.
If,
if,
if things can go sideways in Iran or
Iraq or wherever the fuck it is,
they can go sideways in America too.
And if you don't think that we need
military,
your God damn crazy cause I would love
it if we didn't.
I would love it if we lived in this
utopian world where everybody treats
people the way you were.
I would,
well you don't have to worry about if
you were in our neighbors,
I would never worry about you invading
me.
You know I'd be like Oh cam is never
going to like bring a gun over and
fucking take over my house.
He's a nice guy.
If the world was like that,
it would be wonderful.
It would be wonderful.
But right now it's not currently right
like that and people that I know like
Tim Kennedy,
a guy who's been there,
I was done that got like Jocko willink.
The guy has been there.
Those are the guys that I turned to when
I want,
when I want to know like what's going on
over there.
I want to get a real perspective.
You want to get a real perspective for
someone who's been in active duty in a
combat situation,
who's been to these horrific parts of
the world.
Right.
They can tell you what's going on and
when they tell you that it's a better
situation that the military has the
handcuffs off.
I listened to them.
That's a good sign.
Yeah.
I,
yeah.
I talked to Tim at shot show and he,
you know,
I about going back in and he said that
same thing.
I mean,
I don't know.
It just,
it feels like a,
I dunno,
it feels better that we're not having
the terrorist issues over here anymore.
Yeah.
I mean,
I really wish that everyone would come
back home.
I really wished that no one was in
Afghanistan.
I really wished that we weren't the
police people for the world.
I really wished that we're not sending
young people to die and in foreign wars
that don't make any sense to you or I or
anybody that really knows what the fuck
is going on there.
But this is the world we live in right
now.
Yeah.
You know,
energy it the best we can protect us,
protect people here.
Yeah.
And hopefully protect people there too.
You know,
it's just now that's why you got to
respect the people that are over there
doing that and,
and he does just like,
you know,
what a sacrifice,
and it's uh,
I want to never take it for granted that
there are,
you know,
we're safe here.
Things are going on,
but just what's the sacrifices made by
people in the military?
It's a,
I never want to forget it.
Yeah.
It is a very controversial subject with
people because um,
if you're on the left,
you want less military,
you want less war,
you want less violence,
you want less everything and that,
that's a totally reasonable position.
But I think in a lot of ways it's like
wildlife,
like you're talking about it as someone
who's never experienced it.
And I think once you experience it,
and once you've been to these parts of
the world,
at least my perspective,
based on the descriptions that I've
gotten from people that have been there
or that it's,
it's way more complex.
There are just parts of the world that
are fucked.
Yeah.
Now,
yeah,
it's an,
it's not black and white,
that's for sure.
And I think it's going to take many,
many generations for those parts of the
world to become a better place for
people to live in and then sort of catch
up to what we think of as civilization,
the Western world.
And Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
you're looking at parts of the Middle
East where the women in Iran are risking
their lives and their safety by not
wearing a religious outfit.
Yeah.
There's all these protests where these
women are on the streets were not
wearing the hijab and they're walking
around and they risk being imprisoned
now.
It's amazing.
Fucking crazy.
And these women are brave as hell,
man.
And they're out there just saying fuck
this enough already.
And they're taking pictures like that
and they're,
they're putting it up on social media
and you know,
there's a,
a big revolt there right now where
people are just tired of it.
They want fucking freedom,
you know,
and they see what's going on in the rest
of the world.
They have the Internet,
they didn't get a chance to see what's
going on in America.
And that's one of the things that we
always have to remember about America.
Yeah.
America might be fucked in some ways and
there's,
we definitely have issues,
but there is more opportunity and more
possibility for you to do what you want
to do here than almost anywhere on the
planet earth as a fact.
That's a fact.
Yeah.
And there's more art that comes out of
here and there's more comedy that comes
out of here.
There's more,
there's so much shit,
more movies.
There's,
there's a lot of great shit that comes
out of this one spot.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a great place to,
I mean we're,
we're blessed to live here and have w
we've only known this,
you know,
and I couldn't imagine living someplace
where it wouldn't matter how smart or
how hard of a worker you are or how,
you know,
whatever talented you were,
you weren't getting out of there.
And that's how it is in some places.
And so,
you know,
in here it's not like that.
And Man,
I just,
I just hope we never,
I never need to forget that and I never
want to forget that.
And I just hope other people just
realize that because it's not like I've
been everywhere.
But I just,
I know that the,
the challenge is like the women have
that you were talking about.
It's like,
I couldn't imagine that.
Yeah.
Look,
one of the reasons why I'm Pro America
is cause I'm pro human being.
Yeah.
And I think there's more,
there's more chances for people to be
who they really want to be and become
what they really want to be here.
You know?
And I support a lot of left wing ideas,
equality and freedom and gay marriage.
I think he should be able to do whatever
the fuck you want to do.
I mean,
go have fun,
just be nice.
Don't just do b,
you just go be you.
So when you know,
people see me and they like spent like
to see this giant American flag behind
me and they think immediately,
oh,
right wing,
fucking conservative.
All right.
Or whatever.
This is,
what is this?
What do you support?
Imperialism,
you support this?
Like no,
I support the idea of what America is.
Yeah.
That's what I support.
Yeah,
me too.
Fuck yeah.
Woo.
So elk hunting September and we back
same spot going to the desert rat.
Is that,
is that locked in?
Hell yeah.
That was crazy.
Yeah.
That's a beautiful place.
Now.
I know.
That was one of the most fun times I've
ever had.
Yeah.
Well we're getting it.
We're going to do it again.
I'm excited.
Me Too.
470,000 views.
That video was a lot of fun to make too,
man.
I just wish that they had put in,
uh,
the,
the elk that you shot your elk,
you did wind up shooting out a,
an elk,
but did,
did the,
the video that did not get the actual
Arrow hitting the elk on camera.
So what the issue was,
it's tough.
You know,
bow hunting is hard,
you know,
in film and so it's,
uh,
you know,
we do the best we can to tell the story.
Um,
I don't think it does tell the story
very well.
No,
but we do the best we can.
It is hard,
you know,
I mean she'd be a lot longer.
That's what I think.
I think,
um,
I think that things should have been at
least an hour and I think,
um,
even then it wouldn't have told the
whole story because you look at it like,
it's one of the things that uh,
I've told a friend when we were watching
uh,
a hunting show before,
they're like,
wow,
it looks so easy.
They just go out there and they always
shoot something.
I'm like,
man,
to shoot one of these shows,
like we were watching meat eater.
First of all,
meat eaters,
one of the rare shows that they'll have
a lot of shows where they don't,
they're not successful.
Like I've done two different shows with
them.
We were weren't successful.
We just go out.
There are seven days most hunting,
most hunting.
Yeah.
So when you boil all that down to 22
minutes with commercials,
yeah.
It just looks like it inevitably you're
going to get to about 18 minutes in,
someone's going to shoot something.
Yay.
They got it.
It seems like you're shooting things
that are definitely going to be there,
but that's not,
that's not the case.
Now.
There's no guarantee,
especially with the ball,
especially with the bow.
I and I think,
well,
I mean we can film on ourselves.
We can feel ourselves as long as we
want.
That's what I think we should do.
I've been thinking about that a lot
because I was frustrated by that whole
thing and this archaic idea that
everything has to be 10 minutes long.
You're talking to a guy that does a
three hour podcasts that talking for
quite a while today and millions of
people listen to this,
so I just,
I don't buy it.
I think it's an archaic,
antiquated way of looking at things.
I don't think it's right and I think
this idea that people have an incredibly
short attention span.
Listen,
people are consumers of entertainment
and especially people who love hunting.
I watch a lot of videos.
I watch a lot of hunting videos.
I'll watch a lot of videos on science.
I launch a lot of shit.
I watch hours and hours of stuff,
things that I'm interested in.
The people that are interested in elk
hunting.
They don't want to just see a couple of
guys laughing and joking around and an
Arrow hits a big bowl
and everybody's happy.
No.
They want to see like what,
what?
What happened?
Like what was the struggle?
There was a lot of struggle.
There was a lot of damage.
We did have to keep hammering.
That was fun.
That was,
that was that one clip was hilarious.
That was told,
by the way,
folks who listen to this or watching
this,
if you watch that clip of Cam and I,
that was not rehearsed now.
That just came out of nowhere.
We were just fucking around.
We will keep hammering.
He's been around a little while,
so he's been around a long time.
They thought that was the origins of it.
Did that.
That was because that's how good we sold
it.
Yeah.
That's how good we sold that thing.
Well that's your sense of humor and I
think most people are not aware of that.
This is what you say.
That's fair.
You have a very funny dry sense of
humor.
You know?
That was a,
that was fun.
Yeah,
we had,
it was a lot of fun.
So let's come in.
This time is Adam to green tree.
You're going to come down a alert to
Utah?
Yes.
Oh,
I don't know.
This is,
listen,
underarmour.
His shit together.
This is what we need.
Remy,
Warren,
Adam Green Tree.
John Dudley,
Cam Haines,
me,
Ben O'brian.
Make it happen.
Salad.
Wrap it up.
Make a video.
An hour long.
How about just under armour?
Let me film it.
I just let me handle this because I
don't know what the fuck you're doing.
I think 10 minutes.
I know.
I think we can,
uh,
I just want to,
man,
I've always wanted to just share a
hunting adventure.
Just the real hunger adventure.
Give it to constant content.
Uh,
the time to develop the story.
Just,
just let it evolve.
You know?
Do you watch those hush and guys on a,
on youtube now I have great videos.
Are they good?
Yeah.
And they've got a lot of content in.
One of the things that you really get
out of their content is you really get a
sense of how difficult it is.
And mostly what they're doing is public
land hunting.
Well,
born and raised.
There's that stuff,
that group of guys.
Yeah,
I'll watch that.
I watched those guys too.
Yeah.
But one of the beautiful things about
youtube is there's no time parameters.
No.
And people,
yeah.
I mean we are just kind of locked into
this 22 minutes with the commercials
type thing from the outdoor channel and
it doesn't need to be,
like I was talking with a brand and
shockey about this back at [inaudible]
and he's so talented as far as a film
maker goes and,
and uh,
even in womack who put together our
Utah,
I mean without the handcuffs of a time
restraint.
I just think there's,
the sky's the limit.
I agree too.
I think the story should be what the
story is and just say,
just make it what it is.
You don't,
I don't give a fuck of it's 40 minutes
or an hour and 40 minutes.
People will watch it.
Yeah.
And the ones who don't,
they weren't going to watch it anyway.
The ones that,
the idea that like you get it in 10
minutes and somehow or another it's more
digestible in 10 minutes.
Like stop.
That's not real.
This is a,
people have these weird ideas in their
head about things like,
oh,
but the statistics show that more people
watch 10 minute videos.
Well if you want him watch videos about
babies chewing bubblegum or some stupid
shit like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
the 10 minutes.
But you're supposed to be showing
respect to what is one of the more
difficult and misunderstood pursuits in
the United States.
Right.
And that's bow hunting,
right?
It's incredibly difficult and incredibly
misunderstood.
And I think it's a noble pursuit and I
think it's also,
it's one of the more intriguing things
and more interesting things I've ever
done in my life.
Well,
I know,
and I don't know if you captured all in
one film,
but I just know that,
you know,
if somehow we could capture the,
just the more of the journey because
there's people that don't know anything
about it.
This one or know how to get started.
I don't know if you'd have one film that
I'd do all of that,
but I just know that there's people
hungry for knowledge out there that
we're,
we're reaching even with this podcast or
with social media that haven't been in
great.
So it's like we're making these films to
people who already hunters,
right.
I already know everything.
And so to them,
oh we got to do this in a short period
of time of those are gonna get bored
because they've done this a million
times themselves.
Well does bullshit.
No.
That we need to,
to make it for the masses.
Exactly.
Cause that's who we're reaching now.
Yeah.
I mean it's the millions and millions
and millions.
We're reaching more people than actually
by hunting licenses.
So we need to keep that,
keep re need to remember that.
Yeah.
And the idea that you're even reaching
hunters,
that they're going to get bored after 10
minutes.
That's crazy now.
Yeah.
Cause I'm like you,
I watch all sorts of hunting stuff,
especially you and me.
We're in attaining is fuck let it roll.
Yeah.
Like the uh,
what,
what were we saying?
Oh yeah,
with the,
with the um,
chicken tied to the dog neck.
It was one of the funniest things cams
ever said.
He was talking about,
uh,
this guy,
his dog was,
my dogs killed a few chickens and I'm
like,
fuck,
how'd you get your dog to stop killing
chickens?
He goes,
oh,
we tied a dead chicken to his neck and
cam goes and she's tired.
Dead stripper to your neck.
And it was just out of the blue and I
was fucking crying,
laughing.
But that,
that was one of the funniest things you
said.
But there was one other one.
What was the other one?
We had a hard time remembering it.
Remember the other one that you had said
before?
Yeah,
it was even funnier than that.
But my point is he's got fucking standup
comedy timing.
That sounds like something that,
like one of my comic friends would've
said,
oh,
okay,
I wish I could remember the other one
was another one that was funny.
Or I now fuck I now,
God dammit,
we laughed about it.
The dead stripper tied your neck for a
long,
many times.
Many times.
It's also too,
at the end of the day,
kind of exhaust higher delirious dinner.
Yeah.
That's sort of,
the timing comes in.
Exactly.
Well,
it's like those hunting camps are so
much fun.
Like you at the end of the day,
you and me and Ben sitting around
laughing,
cracking jokes,
it's half fun of it.
The family up there,
the land family love those guys of the
earth.
No,
Tom Land and his boys,
they just,
it's just,
it's just fun to be,
they feel like family when you go back
up there.
He'll feel,
feel that this year,
you know,
he's a great guy.
The whole staff they had there was
fantastic.
It says a,
an awesome place and it's such a
beautiful piece of land.
You know,
this is 240,000 acres.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's,
you know,
I know we're probably wrapping this up,
but so when you talk about hunting and
conservation real quick,
you know,
on that piece of property 240 they could
make more money by running cattle on it,
right?
Do you realize that?
But if they ran cattle on it,
the habitat would be thrashed right
there.
The water sources,
it'd be thrashed.
All those flowers,
the grouse that lived there gone because
it's just cattle.
But if his goal was making money,
they could just do that.
But the goal is,
is to make money but also enhance the
habitat and that's,
you know,
hunting is the best way to do that.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's just a magical place.
Like the mule deer that we saw wandering
around his big mule deer and they have
everything there,
all sorts of different wildlife.
It's this and it's gorgeous country to
do.
It is beautiful.
Yeah.
All right,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Cameron.
Our Haynes on Instagram,
and is that the same as twitter?
But you don't even use twitter really
right now on facebook.
You use facebook at all anymore.
Little bit.
People die off that,
right?
Instagram's got,
instagram's got it right now.
All right.
Um,
and uh,
next,
next video.
We make folks be about four hours long.
No,
you can't.
The video,
the hunting video.
We're going to keep hammering.
Bye everybody.
Okay.